voilà chers collègues je vous propose
d'attaquer notre deuxième audition de de
l'après-midi je remercie Jean-Marc
Jancovici d'avoir répondu à l'invitation
de notre commission d'enquête visant à
établir les raisons de la perte de la
souveraineté et de l'indépendance
énergétique de la France nous venons de
commencer nos travaux puisque notre
commission s'est installée la semaine
dernière que nous avons eu une première
audition tout à l'heure avec une
anthropologue un historien de l'énergie
et aujourd'hui nous cherchons à brosser
de façon générale un paysage le paysage
énergétique de la France avant
progressivement d'entrer plus en détail
dans le dans le processus
décisionnel alors Monsieur Jean-Côme ici
vous êtes professeur à mine ParisTech
vous êtes membre du Haut Conseil pour le
climat
pardon
vous étiez alors
amine Paris pardon mine Paris vous étiez
vous êtes membre du Haut Conseil pour le
climat fondateur du shift projet merci
d'avoir répondu à notre demande
d'audition dans des délais extrêmement
contraints qui sont liés à l'agenda de
l'installation de notre de notre
commission vous êtes par ailleurs
relativement connu des Français pour
vous exprimer régulièrement des sur les
sujets d'énergie dans les médias et nous
allons vous donc vous donner sans tarder
la parole pour nous exposer
votre analyse pour un propos introductif
et puis ensuite il y aura des questions
de ma part du rapporteur et puis de la
commission mais en amont s'agissant
d'une commission d'enquête et en vertu
de l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre
1958 relatives au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires vous devez
prêter serment de dire la vérité toute
la vérité rien que la vérité monsieur
jean-clau ici je vous prie donc de lever
la main droite et de dire je le jure je
le jure merci je vous laisse donc la
parole pour un propos introductif très
bien bah en fait mon propos introductif
va être relativement bref parce que
j'imagine que c'est surtout vous qui
avez des questions je vais juste faire
deux commentaires un sur mes titres et
ce au nom duquel je m'exprime ou pas
et le deuxième commentaire que je vais
faire c'est sur l'intitulé même de la
commission d'enquête
en ce qui concerne mes titres donc je
précise que je ne m'exprime au nom
d'aucune des instances pour lesquelles
mon figure ici donc je ne suis pas du
tout habilité à m'exprimer au nom du
Haut Conseil pour le climat qui a une
présidente qui fait ça très bien je suis
pas plus habilité à m'exprimer au nom
des mines ni au nom de carbone CAP ou ce
que je vais vous raconter aujourd'hui
n'engage pas car 24 et ni au nom du gif
project voilà ça donc ça n'engagera que
moi la deuxième chose que je souhaite
préciser en ce qui concerne le titre
même de votre commission la France n'a
jamais été indépendante énergétiquement
depuis qu'elle a quitté l'air des
énergies c'est à dire que nous étions
indépendants énergétiquement à l'époque
où nous utilisons exclusivement les
pierres et le bois du sol français pour
construire des moulins à vent les
pierres du sol français pourri de bois
pour construire des moulins à eau et le
bois français et l'herbe française pour
faire avancer des animaux de traits
depuis que nous sommes rentrés dans
l'ère des combustibles fossiles et de
l'énergie nucléaire et des nouvelles
énergies renouvelables etc en fait nous
ne sommes pas indépendants parce que
nous dépendons une espèce d'imbrication
des énergies je sais pas si l'historien
des énergies qui est venu ici c'est
Jean-Baptiste fresoses non c'est pas lui
mais sinon en fait il y a une
imbrication des énergies qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dégager
une énergie de façon individualisée d'un
système elles sont toutes imbriquées et
par exemple on ne fait pas de réacteur
nucléaire sans métallurgie donc sans
charbon on ne fait pas de panneaux
photovoltaïques sans électricité au
charbon donc son charbon on ne fait pas
on ne fait pas venir depuis la Chine
sans pétrole parce que il faut que ça
vienne donc en fait il y a une
imbrication des énergies aujourd'hui et
sauf à ce qu'un pays maîtrise sur son
sol la mortalité à la fois des sources
énergétiques impliquées donc la totalité
des énergies actuellement utilisées dans
le monde et la totalité des mines
métalliques qui sont nécessaires pour
fournir les dispositifs d'extraction de
l'énergie de l'environnement et de
transformation en des vecteurs
énergétiques qui permettent d'alimenter
nos machines et bien on ne peut pas
parler d'indépendance énergétique ou de
souveraineté énergétique donc en fait
aucun pays ne la possède totalement
l'Arabie saoudite a plus de pétrole que
nous mais elle a pas de mine de fer donc
si elle était à frontière fermée sans
aucune communication avec l'extérieur
elle ne pourrait pas exploiter son
pétrole voilà donc c'était juste un
petit une petite remarque préliminaire
pour dire que les mots ayant un sens
enfin en tout cas j'imagine qu'ils en
ont un dans la Commission dans le titre
de la commission d'enquête
je voulais juste faire remarquer que
l'indépendance ça n'existe pas stricte
au sang et que la bonne question pour
moi me semble être pour l'ensemble du
système énergétique de savoir de qui on
dépend
dans quelle proportion avec quelle
aptitude à ce retourner si jamais on a
un problème avec les gens dont on dépend
voilà c'est ça les bonnes questions et
donc c'est des questions qui sont
nécessairement quantifiées et calendez
avoir un débat c'est pas du tout
agressif ce que je veux dire mais avoir
à débat philosophique sur l'indépendance
en fait c'est très intéressant le soir
passé 23 heures mais sinon dans l'absolu
ça n'a pas beaucoup d'intérêt pratique
et je vais finir ce petit exposé
luminaire en rappelant que la France
quand on regarde ce qu'on appelle
l'énergie finale c'est-à-dire l'énergie
qui alimente les machines qui nous
rendent la vie si douce qu'il s'agisse
des ascenseurs des tractopelles des
trains ou des laminoirs l'essentiel de
l'énergie qui rentre dans une machine en
France qui nous rend un service quelle
qu'elle soit que ce soit de la mobilité
de etc c'est des combustible fossiles et
que la France sauf erreur de ma part ne
possède plus du tout de Gigantes sur son
sol et possède 1% enfin extra extrait de
l'environnement 1% du pétrole qu'elle
consomme
je vais également faire un petit rappel
j'avais dans alors pas dans l'hémicycle
ni dans cette salle mais dans une autre
salle de l'Assemblée il y a très très
longtemps participé à un colloque
organisé par Yves Cochet qui avait fait
rigoler tout le monde à l'époque sur le
pic de production du pétrole ça devait
être une quinzaine d'années je crois je
voudrais rappeler que le pic de
production du pétrole depuis est passé
en ce qui concerne le pétrole
conventionnel c'est-à-dire que tout ce
qui n'est pas le shaila et l'américain
et les sables bitumineux Canadiens est
passé par un maximum en 2008 dans le
monde il y a un lien direct avec ce
qu'on a appelé la crise des subprimes
que depuis ça décline et que en ce qui
concerne l'Europe l'Europe est en
approvisionnement contraint à la baisse
sur son pétrole depuis cette date
ça c'est quelque chose qui est
géologique d'accord que ça nous plaise
ou que ça nous plaise pas ça va
s'accélérer dans les décennies qui
viennent et en particulier il y a un
travail très complet qui a été fait par
le chiffre projet qui est public qui est
disponible sur notre site qui porte sur
les possibilités de production de
pétrole sous sol contraintes géologique
des 16 premiers fournisseurs de l'Europe
qui sont par ailleurs les 16 premiers
producteurs mondiaux hors-brésil et
Canada et la conclusion de ce travail
qui a été menée par deux anciens cadres
dirigeants total et pas n'importe
lesquels puisqu'il s'agissait de la
personne qui était en charge de
l'évaluation des gisements et la
l'exploration c'est que la production de
nos 16 premiers fournisseurs devraient
divisés par deux d'ici à 2050 ce qui
veut dire que leurs exportations vers
l'Europe vont être divisés par n'importe
quoi entre 2 et 20
donc de la perte de souveraineté sur le
pétrole faut s'attendre à en avoir et
pas qu'un peu en ce qui concerne le gaz
le gyprocjet va publier en novembre dans
quelques jours là un travail similaire
qu'on a fait sur le gaz confié à des
personnes de même tabac avec des données
qui sont en qui sont issues du même
endroit c'est-à-dire une base de données
de l'ensemble des gisements de pétrole
et de gaz dans le monde auquel on a
laquelle on a eu accès
et le résultat de ce travail c'est que
le pic de production pour le gaz dans le
monde dans son ensemble c'est 2030 celui
pour la mer du Nord c'était 2005 donc si
on ajoute à ça le fait que le charbon
est en déplétion géologique en Europe
depuis 1950 enfin depuis les années 50
en gros en fait sur toutes les énergies
fossiles l'Europe étant entre guillemets
perte de souveraineté
depuis
2005 pour le gaz
2008 pour le pétrole et les années 50
pour le charbon avant même qu'il y ait
des sujets de climat voilà c'est dans ce
donc il faut bien voir que en fait sur
les énergies fossiles qui sont le
premier moteur de la civilisation dans
lequel nous vivons la question de la
perte de souveraineté elle est déjà à
l'oeuvre depuis longtemps et ça va
s'accélérer et ça va se traduire
directement en contraction de flux de
toute nature que l'on a l'habitude de
résumer classiquement sous l'angle PIB
mais voilà on va avoir un sujet de
contraction des flux de toute façon on
en est en vie ou pas
merci beaucoup pour ce propos
introductif qui qui pose tout de suite
le cadre moi j'aurais du coup quelques
quelques questions avant de laisser la
parole aux rapporteur d'abord une
première question finalement au-delà de
la souveraineté et de l'indépendance
aujourd'hui la dans le débat public et
dans le dans la situation aussi dans
laquelle on se trouve dans les dans les
contraintes pour pour les choix
énergétiques à venir il y a la question
du climat et elle est même centrale et
donc du cycle du cycle carbone
très long sur les énergies fossiles plus
court sur la biomasse absent sur sur les
énergies renouvelables ou sur ou sur le
nucléaire quel est pour vous à l'échelle
du climat le pas de temps acceptable du
cycle carbone alors pourquoi est-ce que
le bois serait acceptable alors que le
charbon ne l'est pas est-ce que vous
pouvez un peu nous détailler ça
oui alors une toute petite remarque
incidente sur votre question en fait les
énergies renouvelables et nucléaires ne
sont pas sans carbone si on regarde en
analyse de cycle de vie puisque comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure il faut du
Charbon Pour faire la métallurgie amont
il faut de la pétrochimie pour faire la
fin de la chimie organique pour faire la
chimie à l'amont etc après il faut
compter et le résultat du décompte n'est
pas le même en ce qui concerne les
différentes énergies renouvelables le
nucléaire etc
la le pas de temps acceptable en général
on raisonne dans le domaine climatique
au pas de temps de l'année c'est-à-dire
que à partir du moment où une émission
et une reprise de l'atmosphère ont lieu
la même année on considère que c'est
neutre c'est ça le c'est ça en général
ce qu'on considère alors en ce qui
concerne les combustibles fossiles les
combustibles fossiles stockent du
carbone qui a été retiré à l'atmosphère
il y a quelques dizaines à quelques
centaines de millions d'années c'est à
peu près le temps qu'il faut pour faire
du gaz du charbon ou du pétrole à partir
de résidus de vie ancienne des fougères
qui ont poussé au carbonifères pour le
charbon et du plancton qui s'est
développé dans la mer n'importe quand
entre il y a 5 millions d'années pour
une petite partie mais surtout n'importe
quand entre 100 et 400 millions d'années
pour le pétrole et gaz puis il s'est
résidus de vie anciennes ont été
enfouies par la tectonique des plaques
sous le sol gentiment distillées par la
géothermie
et tout ça a pris quelques dizaines à
quelques centaines de millions d'années
ce qui veut dire que quand on déstocke
ce carbone accumulé ces poches de soleil
anciennes comme dit très joliment Yann
Arthus-Bertrand dans l'atmosphère quand
on les déstocke et qu'on les remet dans
l'atmosphère on crée une asymétrie entre
le rythme auquel la vie peut reprendre
du carbone de l'atmosphère et le rythme
auquel nous on Déstock le carbone qui
avait été anciennement stocké pour la
biomasse en fait la biomasse n'est pas
nécessairement neutre en carbone c'est
toute la difficulté du décompte ça
dépend dans quel stock on tape
pour que la biomasse soit considérée
comme neutre en carbone il faut taper
dans un stock qui si on ne tapait pas
dedans serait à l'équilibre avec chaque
année une partie des arbres qui meurent
on va dire et de jeunes arbres qui
repoussent et à partir du moment où on
prélève dans un stock qui est à
l'équilibre moins que ce qu'on appelle
la crue Foresti annuelle c'est-à-dire la
quantité de biomasse qui se forme par
photosynthèse à ce moment on considère
qu'on a affaire à une énergie
renouvelable si on prélève plus à ce
moment on a affaire de la déforestation
et c'est pas du tout compter dans les
énergies renouvelables ces contes et
alors c'est toute la difficulté c'est
que dans une partie des réglementations
qui pousse à l'utilisation de la
biomasse en fait on n'est pas capable de
mettre des seuils c'est-à-dire qu'on
n'est pas capable de dire on va
favoriser l'appel à la biomasse jusqu'à
tel niveau parce que après on bascule
dans la déforestation et par ailleurs il
y a quelque chose dont on sait très mal
tenir compte dans ce genre de cas de
figure qui est l'effet les effets
dominos ou les effets de transfert je
vais vous donner un exemple aujourd'hui
on considère que le colza qu'on fait
pousser en france pour faire des
agrocarburants c'est de la biomasse
neutre en carbone mais moi je pourrais
vous dire on pourrait très bien à la
place de ce colza ne pas faire pousser
de colza diminuer la taille des voitures
et par ailleurs à la place du colza
faire pousser du soja et de la luzerne
et éviter dans n'importe quel Brésil et
comme ça éviter de la déforestation
bon donc vous voyez dans le deuxième cas
de figure je peux considérer que le
colza paraît fait d'éviction empêche de
mettre en France des cultures qui elles
vont engendrer de la déforestation
du coup est-ce que je considère que ce
colza il est neutre en carbone ou pas
bah vous voyez ce genre de questions de
méthode qui sont très compliquées quand
il s'agit de faire appel à la biomasse
et en toute état de cause si on raisonne
à l'échelle planétaire au moment où
actuellement à l'échelle planétaire la
terre est en déforestation ce qui veut
dire que à chaque fois que on met
quelque part une culture énergétique bah
on peut se dire que c'est comme c'est la
culture marginale c'est la dernière
qu'on met en oeuvre c'est elle qui est
responsable d'une partie de la
déforestation qu'on pourrait éviter
sinon si on mettait pas en oeuvre cette
culture voilà donc c'est c'est compliqué
les raisonnements sur la biomasse il y a
rien de très simple là-dedans
du coup est-ce que pour décarboner
à l'échelle de la planète à notre notre
économie est-ce que le seul chemin c'est
celui de la décroissance
je pense que c'est quelque chose qu'on
ne va pas réussir à éviter et en fait
quand on regarde les flux physique c'est
quelque chose dans lequel nous sommes
déjà en Europe depuis 2007
2008 c'est-à-dire le passage de la de
l'approvisionnement enfin du maximum de
l'approvisionnement pétrolier si on
regarde les flux physiques de quoi je
parle je parle par exemple de la
quantité de mètres carrés qu'on
construit en Europe qui est passé par un
maximum en 2007 que nous n'avons plus
jamais atteint depuis je parle des
tonnes chargés dans les camions qui sont
passés par un maximum en 2007 et qui n'a
pas été atteint de nouveau depuis je
parle éventuellement de la production
industrielle voilà quand vous regardez
donc en tant que la production
industrielle elle est mesurée en euro
donc là déjà il y a une convention on
n'est plus dans les unités strictement
physiques comme des mètres carrés ou des
tonnes là c'est beaucoup plus facile
donc il faudrait mesurer la production
industrielle en tonne aussi ou en mètre
cube ou en quelque chose de physique et
là on aurait une réponse qui serait
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus clair mais
il n'empêche que un certain nombre
d'indicateurs physiques ou de proxy
d'indicateurs physiques en fait sont
déjà en décrue en Europe depuis
2007-2008
ce qui signifie qu'en fait la
décroissance on s'en rend pas compte
mais on est déjà dedans alors quand je
dis on s'en rend pas compte les élites
urbaines comme nous ça rendent pas
compte parce que nous on fait partie des
préserver du système vous et moi on vit
dans un endroit qui est loin des flux
physique donc en ville les vêtements
arrivent au magasin la nourriture arrive
au supermarché enfin on se rend pas bien
compte de ce qu'il y a à Lamont et donc
c'est voilà donc on n'est pas on n'est
pas les premiers j'ai envie de dire à se
rendre compte avec nos sens et l'essence
ça compte quand même chez les animaux
que nous sommes on n'est pas les
premiers à se rendre compte avec nos
sens de ce qui est en train de se passer
mais en fait on est déjà dans une espèce
de décrue larvé en Europe et les
Italiens s'en rendent très bien compte
les Espagnols et les Portugais s'en
rendent parfaitement compte aussi et
c'est malheureusement quelque chose qui
va s'accélérer parce que les
combustibles fossiles qui sont eux-mêmes
en décrue subis jouent un rôle tellement
central dans l'émergence de la
civilisation dans laquelle nous vivons
que cette décrue ne sera pas compensée
par
aucune autre forme d'énergie décarbonée
dans les temps
compte tenu des ordres de grandeur qui
sont en jeu donc les énergies
décarbonées vont pouvoir jouer un rôle
d'amortisseur donc c'est bien d'en faire
mais ça ne va pas complètement éviter
une remise en cause parce que les
combustibles fossiles sont absolument
partout à commencer par le vêtement que
je porte la cravate que vous portez etc
le vernis de la table sur lequel je
m'appuie tous les composants du micro
dans lequel je parle enfin il y a du
pétrole il y a des résidus de pétrole
enfin ou des dérivés du pétrole plus
exactement partout là dedans et donc
faire une civilisation actuelle sans
combustible fossile personnellement je
n'y crois pas je pense que c'est juste
pas possible
donc là donc avec de moins en moins de
combustible fossiles oui on va avoir
droit à quelque chose qui s'apparentera
alors on va Plon là décroissance
contractions sobriété tout ça c'est des
variantes sémantiques d'un concept qui
est exactement le même c'est-à-dire
qu'on va devoir faire avec moi moins de
choses physiques alors est-ce que c'est
une catastrophe il nous appartient que
la réponse soit non est-ce qu'on va
pouvoir y échapper je ne crois pas pour
des raisons physiques aussi
alors du coup je j'ai deux questions que
je vous pose encore et puis après je
serai à parler en rapporteur
une sur les ressources disponibles sur
notre sur notre sol
vous avez largement évoqué la quantité
de ressources qu'on importe
qu'il soit de minerai d'énergie carbonée
etc comment est-ce qu'on mobilise des
ressources sur notre sol je pense y
compris aux ressources minières le
lithium par exemple les choses comme ça
et puis deuxième question qui est
peut-être un peu détachée mais comment
comment on construit aujourd'hui des
scénarios énergétiques qui puissent être
crédibles on sort d'une période où on a
vu beaucoup de scénarios énergétiques se
contreduit contredire quelle méthode
selon vous est-ce qu'il faudrait qu'on
adopte pour construire des scénarios
énergétiques crédibles
aucune de ces deux questions n'est
simple là sur la première comment est-ce
qu'on fait pour exploiter des ressources
déjà encore faudrait-il qu'on en est
vous savez probablement que en ce qui
concerne le charbon on a plus grand
chose chez nous en ce qui concerne le
minerai de fer on a plus grand chose
chez nous je ne sais pas si on n'a
jamais eu de minerai de cuivre mais je
pense pas qu'il nous en reste beaucoup
donc certes on a certaines ressources
qu'on peut exploiter donc celle-là
éventuellement le on peut le faire par
contre il y en a d'autres pour
lesquelles c'est pas du tout sûr qu'on
en est tout court après il y a une
deuxième chose qu'il faut bien voir en
ce qui concerne les ressources
métalliques c'est qu'il y a un cercle
alors je sais pas si je vois l'appeler
vicieux ou en tout cas d'asservissement
entre l'énergie et les métaux tout
simplement parce que avec le temps la
teneur en métal des minerais baisse et
ça veut dire que il faut de plus en plus
d'énergie pour produire une tonne d'un
métal donné pour vous donner un exemple
si ma mémoire ne me fait pas trop défaut
dans les premières mines de cuivre qui
ont été exploitées dans le monde et
notamment la mine de riotino qui a donné
son nom ensuite au groupe minier éponyme
qui se trouve en Espagne je crois qu'au
début de exploitations minières il y
avait de l'ordre de 15 à 20% de cuivre
en poids dans le minerai aujourd'hui la
teneur moyenne en cuivre en poids dans
le minerai des mines exploitées dans le
monde c'est 04% et donc on est descendu
de 20 à 0,4 et il y a un mouvement
général de baisse de la teneur en métaux
de toutes les mines qu'on exploite dans
le monde
et c'est évidemment pour cette raison là
que une partie des mines françaises ont
été abandonnées parce qu'il y a encore
un peu de ressources en France mais que
les mines françaises ont été abandonnées
tout simplement parce que la teneur
donnait trop basse et que du coup
c'était pas rentable en compétition avec
d'autres gisements dans le monde qui
étaient plus intéressants
donc pour accéder au pour accéder aux
métaux il faut de l'énergie et les
ressources qu'on peut éventuellement
avoir en France elles sont conditionnées
nécessairement à la quantité d'énergie
dont on peut disposer pour accéder aux
métaux en question
et par ailleurs au gisements au gisement
de départ à l'inventaire de départ
on restera nécessairement dépendant pour
partie de choses qui ne viennent pas de
France
quand on regarde par exemple les
quantités de cuivre qui sont impliquées
dans le développement de tout ce qui est
électrique il est évident qu'en France
on peut pas déployer quoi que ce soit de
significatif comme mode renouvelable ou
même pas renouvelable et comme
usage aval électrique sans importer du
cuivre c'est pas possible alors ça sera
peut-être facile ce sera peut-être
difficile j'en sais rien sur le cuivre
il y a une information qui a été publiée
par l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
il y a pas très longtemps 10 ans que les
mines de cuivre en fonctionnement dans
le monde et celles qui sont en cours de
développement donc en cours de
développement ça veut dire que les
infrastructures d'exploitation du
minerai sont en cours de construction
passeraient leur pic entre maintenant et
dans deux ans
et pour ajouter des nouvelles mines
c'est-à-dire pour que des nouveaux
projets voient le jour il faut compter
entre 10 et 15 ans
voilà donc il y a un petit sujet alors
ça m'amène du coup à la deuxième
question qui est comment est-ce qu'on
fait des scénarios crédibles et bien la
réponse c'est très compliqué
au chiffre project on avait modestement
fait un discours de la méthode sur les
scénarios électriques qui nous a valu
ensuite d'avoir des dialogues très
nourris et très fructueux avec RTE sur
la scénarisation électrique donc nous on
n'avait pas proposé un scénario on avait
proposé un mode de réalisation des
scénarios en disant pour que le scénario
soit complet avec le décideur arrive à y
retrouver ses petits il faut absolument
prendre position sur tel point tel point
tel point tel point tel point tel point
tel point et bien préciser ce qui est
une donnée d'entrée ce qui est une
donnée de sortie voilà alors dans les
scénarios énergétiques il y a
aujourd'hui une faiblesse qui est
partagée par à peu près tous les
scénarios qui est que l'économie est une
donnée d'entrée
dans mon point de vue l'économie est une
donnée de sortie c'est parce que nous
avons des ressources que nous sommes
capables d'avoir un système économique
donc l'économie vient d'un système
productif donc un système économique si
il n'y avait pas d'atomes de fer sur
terre
il y aurait pas d'immeubles en tout cas
pas d'immeuble tels que nous les
construisons aujourd'hui avec des
armatures en fer donc la disponibilité
des ressources est une condition est un
facteur limitant
de la production économique
et du coup le la croissance du PIB c'est
une c'est dans ma vision à moi tel que
ça devrait exister dans l'économie alors
j'ai pas dit tout ça ça devrait être une
donnée de sortie d'un modèle dans lequel
on entrait vous mettez les ressources
disponibles et le nombre de gens
capables de travailler c'est ça que vous
devriez mettre en entrée puis derrière
vous avez une production économique or
dans tous les scénarios énergétiques que
je connais en général l'économie est une
donnée d'entrée et l'énergie est quelque
chose qui est appelé par une économie
dont la création vient de mars bon alors
ça c'est une faiblesse qui est partagée
par à peu près tous les scénarios y
compris le scénario de RTE et une autre
faiblesse dans beaucoup de scénarios
économiques c'est qu'on postule que les
prix d'aujourd'hui sont prédictifs de
l'absence de limite ou de limite sur les
quantités de demain dit autrement si ça
vaut pas cher aujourd'hui c'est que
demain on en aura sans limite
bon et ça c'est une deuxième faiblesse
puisque malheureusement les prix d'hier
ne sont absolument pas prédictifs des
quantités de demain on est en train de
le voir en ce moment avec le gaz le gaz
valait pas cher du tout il y a un an et
demi et ça veut pas du tout dire que on
va avoir les du gaz sans problème pour
les deux hivers qui viennent donc c'est
celui-ci plus le suivant donc et celui
d'après du reste donc c'est c'est
ça c'est des faiblesses un peu partagées
par tous les scénarios c'est le fait que
on a du mal à désimbriquer l'économie de
la partie strictement physique dans les
scénarios énergétiques après j'ai envie
de dire les autres faiblesses elles sont
un peu plus secondaires mais alors du
coup ça veut dire que les scénarios
énergétiques qu'on fait aujourd'hui il y
en a aucun qui soit résistant à la
récession c'est à dire que en gros si on
se trouve dans un monde dans lequel nos
moyens sont physiques sont en
décroissance
la question de savoir si le scénario
énergétique est toujours réaliste est
une question qui n'est pas tranchée
d'une manière générale dans l'ensemble
des scénarios il y a pas ça et ce qui
est très étonnant c'est que même les
scénarios de sobriété par exemple les
scénario 2050 de la dame qui viennent
d'être publié sont des scénarios dans
lesquels il y a de la croissance
économique
voilà donc de mon point de vue à ce
niveau là il y a une contradiction
le président merci Monsieur jean-covici
pour ses premiers mots
énergiques dans la continuité des
questions du président peut-être
reprendre ce que vous avez dit en
introduction sur laquelle la manière
dont vous avez qualifié l'absence
d'indépendance énergétique de tout temps
enfin en tout cas depuis très très
longtemps dans notre pays et vous
demandez peut-être de qualifier
l'évolution de cette dépendance depuis
la prière
elle a alors au sens de la valeur
ajoutée elle a baissé la dépendance
puisque on a coutume de considérer le
nucléaire comme étant une production
domestique alors en termes de valeur
ajoutée c'est tout à fait exact enfin
c'est très largement exact il faut
importer moins d'un euro d'uranium par
mégawattheure électrique produit avec du
nucléaire en France donc effectivement
dans un mégawattheure nucléaire qui
coûte 50 euros on peut considérer que
enfin en ordre de grandeur on peut
considérer que 1 euro c'est une part qui
est parfaitement négligeable si on
raisonne en termes de dépendance
c'est-à-dire si l'étranger n'existait
pas est-ce qu'on pourrait toujours faire
fonctionner le système français à ce
moment on n'est pas plus indépendant sur
le nucléaire que sur le reste par contre
on n'est pas dépendant de la même
manière et en particulier si je compare
aux hydrocarbures
on a un confort j'ai envie de dire
temporel qui n'est pas exactement le
même en ce qui concerne les
hydrocarbures comme vous le savez
probablement on a trois mois de stock en
France c'est-à-dire que si demain matin
tous nos fournisseurs nous coupe les
vivres sur le pétrole le pays fonctionne
trois mois et puis ça s'arrête alors en
fait il s'arrêtera même bien avant parce
qu'il y a des stocks stratégiques qu'on
utilisera pas parce que on les gardera
pour l'armée les ambulances et je sais
pas quoi donc très vite le pays s'arrête
en ce qui concerne l’uranium on peut
stocker des années de fonctionnement sur
le sol et des années ça laisse un peu
plus de temps pour se retourner si on a
un problème avec un fournisseur que
trois mois
sur le voilà donc en gros on a en
passant des hydrocarbures au nucléaires
ce qui est la décision qu'on a prise
dans la production électrique dans les
années 60 70
bien évidemment nous avons gagné en
confort
stricto sensu on peut pas dire qu'on est
gagné en indépendance par contre on a
gagné en confort et on a gagné on part
de valeur ajoutée qui est réalisé sur le
sol français versus ce qui est fait à
l'étranger on a aussi gagné même si
c'était pas le but à l'époque mais du
coup c'est quand même un atout précieux
sur les émissions de CO2
merci beaucoup est-ce que si je reprends
ce que vous venez de dire en prospectif
ça veut dire que un réinvestissement de
la filière nucléaire ou bien à
technologie constante ou marginalement
évolutive si on prend les EPR ou à
technologie différente avec les neutrons
rapides ou très différentes avec la
fusion on pourrait on pourrait on ne
gagnerait qu'en confort à nouveau mais
pas en indépendance
c'est bon
alors on ne gâtent stricto sensu on ne
gagnerait toujours pas en indépendance
parce que par exemple pour faire une
centrale nucléaire il faut du chrome on
n'a pas de chrome en France il faut du
cuivre on n'a pas de cuivre en France
donc c'est toujours pareil si on veut
être stricte sur les termes non on ne
gagne pas on indépendance on a toujours
besoin d'un fournisseur étranger mais on
gagne en confort
on gagne en confort et on gagne en
quantité alors en ce qui concerne le
cuivre si mes derniers chiffres sont
exacts parce qu'il y avait un document
de l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
qui donnait ça il me semble que le
rapport entre le solaire et le nucléaire
c'est de l'ordre de grandeur c'est plus
de 10 sur la quantité de cuivre par
kilowatt-heure produit
donc dans un cas comme dans l'autre si
on veut faire du décarboné on a on est
moins dépendant si on fait du nucléaire
que si on fait un système solaire et
d'une manière générale les énergies
renouvelables qui exploitent des sources
diffuses donc le vent et le soleil ont
besoin de plus de collecteurs
pour avoir la même quantité d'énergie à
l'arrivée sans parler du fait qu'en plus
il faut concentrer parce qu'aujourd'hui
on vit dans une civilisation de la
puissance donc on a besoin de sources
concentrées il faut enfin en tout cas si
on veut maintenir un système qui est pas
trop éloigné du système actuel d'après
on peut débattre d'autres choses
il faut concentrer et il faut
éventuellement stocker parce que les
hydrocarbures assurent également la
fonction de stock j'ai envie de dire par
construction
tout ça demande également des moyens
supplémentaires et donc à chaque fois
des métaux en plus
donc stricto sensu développé la filière
nucléaire je le répète c'est pas être
indépendant puisqu'on a toujours besoin
de fournisseurs de métaux étrangers
c'est être moins dépendant au niveau des
métaux que d'autres options
dans les dans les trois choses que vous
avez citées alors il y en a une qu'on
peut exclure tout de suite c'est la
fusion
la fusion mes enfants seront morts que
ce sera toujours pas quelque chose qui
va changer la donne de façon
significative dans l'approvisionnement
électrique des carbonée je voudrais
quand même rappeler que ITER aujourd'hui
c'est un dispositif qui a seulement pour
objet
de produire un peu plus d'énergie avec
la fusion du plasma que l'énergie qui a
été nécessaire pour mettre le placement
en chauffe à quelques millions de degrés
par ailleurs ITER ne comporte aucun
dispositif électrogène et je ne sais pas
si aujourd'hui on sait faire un
dispositif électrogène avec du
rayonnement gamma et des neutrons
puisque c'est essentiellement ça qu'on
va récupérer d'un réacteur à fusion
alors que dans un réacteur affiché on
récupère de l'eau chaude c'est quand
même un peu plus simple
donc le voilà donc critère on oublie ça
va pas changer grand chose avant que les
gens dans cette salle ne passe de vie à
très pas
en ce qui concerne la quatrième
génération pour moi c'est le gros
déterminant du fait que on est un
nucléaire entre guillemets durable à
l'avenir ou pas
le nucléaire qu'on exploite aujourd'hui
exploite comme vous le savez
probablement un isotope très minoritaire
de l'uranium l'uranium 235 qui est
présent à environ 07% dans l'uranium
naturel
les quantités
récupérables d'uranium sur Terre en
ordre de grandeur
font que si on voulait remplacer
toujours sur terre si on raisonne CO2
une fraction significative des centrales
à charbon mondial par de l'uranium enfin
par de nucléaire il y a pas assez
d'uranium de 135 pour que ce truc là
flotte pendant des siècles
il n'a pas assez donc il faut absolument
si on veut que le nucléaire soit durable
passer à la quatrième génération qui
elle est capable d'exploiter soit
l’uranium de 138 soit du thorium
et il faut le faire dans pas trop
longtemps parce que pour démarrer ces
réacteurs de quatrième génération on a
quand même besoin du seul matériau
difficile qu'on trouve sur terre qui est
l’uranium de 135 donc le jour où il y a
plus d'uranium 235 du tout c'est
évidemment caricatural comme mais pour
bien faire comprendre on ne peut plus
démarrer de réacteurs de 4e génération
c'est plus possible
est-ce que si la France passait à la
quatrième génération on augmenterait
notre indépendance oui on serait capable
d'exploiter les stocks d'uranium 238
qu'on a accumulé très bien mais en fait
ça ne change pas grand chose dans le
panorama d'ensemble parce que je le
redis on continue à avoir besoin
d'importer d'autres métaux pour
construire les réacteurs pour etc et le
poids de l'uranium dans l'affaire est
pas quelque chose d'absolument
fondamental
c'est toujours bon à prendre
mais l'argument premier pour passer à la
quatrième génération il est pas qu'on a
accumulé des stocks d'uranium 238 en
France il est que à l'échelle mondiale
j'ai envie de dire c'est le seul
nucléaire qui puisse être réellement
durable
pour continuer dans le panorama que vous
faites vous avez parlé des hydrocarbures
fin des fossiles en général là du
nucléaire et peut-être vous pouvez nous
dresser le tableau pour un certain
nombre d'énergie renouvelables à la fois
en capacité en capacité à sécuriser les
approvisionnements à moyen terme et puis
bien sûr en capacité de métaux et de
fiabilité
en ce qui concerne les énergies
renouvelables la France elle est avec
une un trio de tête qui ressemble
beaucoup à ce qu'on a dans le monde
puisque les trois premières énergies
renouvelables dans le monde sont alors
sous réserve de ce que j'ai dit en
ouverture sur la déforestation d'abord
la biomasse c'est la première énergie
renouvelable qu'on utilise dans le monde
ensuite arrive l'hydroélectricité c'est
à dire le l'exploitation des fleuves
et en troisième arrive l'éolien et en
fait en France on a le même trio de tête
c'est-à-dire que la première énergie
renouvelable en français le bois la
deuxième c'est le
hydroélectricité et la troisième
maintenant c'est l'éolien
les perspectives pour ces différentes
énergies renouvelables sont assez
différentes alors en ce qui concerne le
bois ces conditionné par l'évolution de
la forêt or notre forêt elle va être
mise à mal par le réchauffement
climatique à condition climatiques
stabilisée c'est-à-dire si demain matin
le réchauffement s'arrêtait on a quand
même 10% de la forêt française qui va
mourir
dans un monde à 2 degrés on se rapproche
plutôt de 40 ou 50%
des espèces actuelles vous avez le être
qui disparaît quasiment vous avez une
bonne partie des chaînes qui vont
disparaître vous avez l'épicéa qui
disparaît en pleine une bonne partie des
sapins qui disparaissent etc donc et
quand je dis ça je me réfère à des
simulations qui ont été faites avec
toutes les réserves qu'on peut avoir
sachant que ces dernières années ce qui
s'est vraiment passé en France est allé
plutôt plus vite du mauvais côté de la
barrière que les simulations dont
j'avais connaissance il y a 10 ans donc
c'est voilà malheureusement le
j'ai envie de dire le l'évolution elle
est plutôt plus désagréable que l'idée
qu'on pouvait s'en faire et si on
commence à avoir un dépérissement
forestier généralisé avoir beaucoup de
biomasse enfin oui on aura les arbres
morts mais après on aura plus rien quoi
donc ça ça c'est quelque chose qui est
voilà il y a cette hypothèque là sur
l'approvisionnement en biomasse en ce
qui concerne l'hydroélectricité on va
avoir un stress hydrique là qui va nous
desservir puisque globalement les
simulations en ce qui concerne le
réchauffement climatique montre un
assèchement
sur le pourtour du bassin méditerranéen
dont les Alpes au sens large font partie
enfin le en particulier la partie sud
donc il va y avoir un sujet
en fait ça peut remonter même assez au
nord puisque cette année je sais pas si
vous avez vu passer cette information et
la Norvège à des réservoirs de barrages
qui sont très mal remplis donc la
sécheresse est allée suffisamment au
Nord en Europe pour que la Norvège
évoque même la possibilité d'exporter
moins d'électricité que d'habitude ce
qui a fait hurler le Danemark qui a
besoin des échanges avec la Norvège pour
équilibrer l'intermittence de son parc
éolien extrêmement développé
donc l'hydroélectricité est un voilà il
y a un sujet et on peut pas tellement la
développer beaucoup plus en France alors
on peut faire de la microhydraulique
mais le dictionnaire est bien fait micro
hydraulique ça fait des microproductions
donc même si on fait beaucoup de
micro-production à l'arrivée ça fait pas
quelque chose qui va changer
significativement la donne à l'échelle
française c'est toujours bon à prendre
là où on peut le faire sans engendrer de
nuisances écologique éventuellement
remettre des mettre des alternateurs sur
sa tête en haut de moulin etc mais ça va
pas faire des volumes considérables
après arrive les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables alors arrivent de
contribution en particulier les pompes à
chaleur et l'éolien
en ce qui concerne l'éolien c'est très
simple on compte l'énergie électrique
qui sort d'une éolienne quand les pales
sont mises en mouvement par la force du
vent
la limite les alors là l'avantage de
l'éolien c'est qu'effectivement une fois
construite l'éolienne n'engendrent pas
des missions
les limites sont que comme ça exploite
une énergie relativement diffuse parce
que l'air c'est pas très dense voilà
donc dans le MI de MV2 donc dans un
mètre cube d'air en mouvement il y a pas
beaucoup d'énergie cinétique et donc il
faut construire beaucoup d'éoliennes
pour récupérer des quantités
significatives d'électricité ça veut
dire avoir beaucoup de projets
et donc à ce moment il y a beaucoup
d'endroits où il y a des gens qui sont
éventuellement capables de discuter
alors on peut soit leur dire vous
discutez pas soit discuter les deux
options des avantages et des
inconvénients et ensuite le vent n'est
pas toujours régulier en permanence
et une éolienne il faut savoir que ça
puisse dépend du cube du vent donc si
vous divisez la vitesse du vent par deux
la puissance électrique fournie est
divisée par 8
ce qui veut dire que et quand vous
regardez à l'échelle de l'Europe même
avec l'interconnexion de toutes les
éoliennes européennes l'ensemble du parc
éolien européen peut descendre à deux
rarement mais il y a quelques moments
dans l'année où il descend à moins de 5%
de la puissance installée pour
l'ensemble de l'Europe donc on ne peut
pas avoir un système qui est purement
éolien
et même en rajoutant du soleil qui est
un peu contracyclique par rapport à
l'éolien parce que vous avez plutôt de
l'éolien de l'hiver quand il y a peu de
soleil et plutôt du soleil il était
quand il y a peu de vent donc vous avez
deux systèmes contracycliques enfin un
peu contracyclique l'ensemble des deux
ne permet qu'en toujours pas d'avoir un
approvisionnement garanti
donc quand on donc c'est donc ces
énergies là elles ont comme limite une
limite en emplacement il faut avoir
beaucoup d'emplacements et une limite en
matériaux c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure puisque elles sont beaucoup plus
intensives en métal que les modes
centralisés
que nous avons l'habitude d'utiliser
jusqu'à maintenant
donc c'est des limites qui sont plutôt
physiques à contrario des limites du
nucléaire qui sont plutôt des limites de
compétences
et de consensus j'ai envie de dire la
limite côté nucléaire elle est plus du
côté de la volonté humaine la limite
côté nouvelle énergie renouvelables et
plus du côté des barrières physiques si
je si je suis pas en train de dire que
la volonté humaine c'est une limite qui
est plus simple à franchir peut-être pas
dire ce que j'ai pas dit elle peut être
beaucoup plus compliqué mais
les pompes à chaleur ça exploite le
transfert d'énergie entre
l'environnement et l'intérieur d'un
logement ou l'intérieur d'une usine
parce qu'on peut faire des pompes à
chaleur haute température pour les
procédés industriels pour faire de la
vapeur industrielle
avec un cycle thermodynamique qui se
trouve à voir en général l'avantage
d'avoir un rendement supérieur
c'est-à-dire que pour 1 kilowattheure
d'électricité que vous injectez dans la
machine vous transférez plusieurs
kilowattheure de chaleur entre
l'extérieur et l'intérieur d'un logement
c'est une contribution aujourd'hui qui
commence à devenir significative mais
c'est une énergie renouvelable à c'est
un peu un pas un paradoxe qui a besoin
d'électricité pour être mise en oeuvre
et donc moi j'avais fait un petit calcul
d'ordre grandeur si on voulait remplacer
l'ensemble du chauffage au gaz dans ce
pays par des pompes à chaleur après
avoir préalablement isolé l'ensemble des
bâtiments
on en a quand même pour quelques
dizaines de terrawateurs d'électricité à
trouver on peut les trouver
enfin on peut les trouver on peut
décider de les faire mais voilà c'est
pas quelque chose quand même qu'on va
trouver sous le pied d'un cheval
après arrive des contributions qui sont
plus mineures dans lesquels on va
trouver les agro-carburants on va
trouver le solaire on va trouver la
géothermie voilà on va trouver des
choses comme ça qui sont qui sont plus
marginales
il y a aucune de ces énergies
renouvelables
pour lesquelles on puisse se dire quand
on regarde bien
il y a pas de problème à leur expansion
indéfinie
voilà c'est ça le problème
une dernière question enfin un paquet de
questions pour ma part qui a plus très à
votre expérience et votre participation
au débat public depuis de nombreuses
années le discours sur les énergies
nucléaires sur la production d'énergie
nucléaire en France a beaucoup varié
patient prend une borne arbitraire des
années 80 à aujourd'hui de la
préparation à la fermeture de super
phénix des décisions prises dans les
années 2000 jusqu'à la fermeture de la
centrale de Fessenheim jusqu'au jusqu'au
discours du président de la République
de Belfort en tant que participant au
débat public à la fois avec les
décideurs politiques mais aussi dans les
universités dans le débat public qu'elle
regarde vous portez sur toutes ces
évolutions et à quelle cause quelle
cause vous lui attribuer attribuer
je me méfie beaucoup de en ce qui me
concerne du fait que je vois à midi à ma
porte comme beaucoup de gens quand on
regarde les sondages sur les Français et
l'énergie en fait on se rend compte que
ce qui va beaucoup compter c'est le prix
et après il y a beaucoup d'autres trucs
qui comptent quand même beaucoup moins
ce que je constate quand même c'est que
les systèmes énergétiques qui vivent sur
un pas de temps qui n'est pas celui de
la démocratie donc en gros
le gros problème des débats sur
l'énergie
c'est que il porte toujours sur des pas
de temps qui sont un ordre de grandeur
en dessous
de ce qu'il faudrait regarder
on s'intéresse à ce qu'on va faire dans
les années qui viennent alors qu'il
faudrait que on ait quelque chose d'un
peu construit sur les décennies qui
viennent et qu'on y revienne pas tous
les quatre matins donc en fait il faut
arriver à créer un consensus dans la
population parce qu'il y a que le
consensus dans la population qui
transcende les alternances électorales
sur la façon dont il faut se réaliser et
ensuite qu'on en dévie pas trop en
espérant que la première et le premier
jet que le coût d'essai soit un coup de
maître c'est à dire que le premier jet
et la première copie qu'on rend sur la
bonne parce que quand on a quand on est
dans une course contre la montre ce qui
est notre cas à la fois avec le
changement climatique et avec
l'épuisement de ce qui a fait la
civilisation moderne on va pas avoir
droit et c'est erreur 50 fois c'est
absolument évident
et là en fait on va déjà payer le prix
d'une partie des essais erreurs qu'on a
fait dans le passé
j'ai je ne suis pas en mesure de savoir
moi-même comment expliquer très
exactement ce qui s'est passé sur les 20
dernières années donc je continue à
fouiller à essayer de me construire une
histoire je suis pas au bout de ma quête
donc je ne sais pas pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y a eu un certain il y a des
épisodes isolés qu'on est capable de de
reproduire par exemple il fait
absolument aucun doute dans mon esprit
que la partie 50% de nucléaire et
fermeture de Fessenheim c'est Hollande
qui voulait un accord avec les verres
donc ça je suis capable de le
caractériser de le dater etc c'est un
épisode mais il y a c'était exactement
pareil en ce qui concerne j'ose pas et
super Phoenix mais par contre il y a
d'autres trucs pour lesquels je suis
c'est très difficile pour moi
d'essayer d'expliquer dans dans son
ensemble un truc par exemple que je suis
pas capable d'expliquer
c'est pourquoi est-ce que le pétrole est
si absent du débat public en France le
pic de production du pétrole tout le
monde s'en fout je redis qu'on cocher
avait organisé son coloc ici ça avait
fait rigoler tout le monde
et encore aujourd'hui quand vous
expliquez qu'on est déjà rentré en
décrue subit d'approvisionnement
pétrolier les gens vous regardent avec
des yeux comme des soucoupes jamais
parlé etc on a un peu commencé à parler
du gaz depuis que Monsieur Poutine nous
fait des misères mais enfin si nous
avons on n'en parlait pas trop donc
voilà donc il y a une focalisation sur
l'électricité dans le débat public qui
ne vous aura pas échappé
et en particulier sur un antagonisme
nucléaire et nucléaire renouvelable
renouvelable électrique je précise
puisqu'encore une fois la première
redouble en français le bois qui est pas
électrique
qui fait les choux gras de la presse et
qui nous occupe beaucoup mais il y a des
questions pour lesquelles j'ai toujours
pas de réponse je ne sais toujours pas
pourquoi est-ce que le débat public
c'est structuré avec
on se focalisant sur certains points
pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a des décisions
à certains moments qui ont été prises
enfin voilà je j'ai pas j'ai pas encore
les idées totalement claires sur le
sujet mais bon
pardon les toutes dernières heures parce
que vous y incitez sur le niveau
d'information de la population du grand
public des décideurs publics au sens
large
en termes de connaissances du domaine
énergétique et l'implication sur les
décisions prises
il est faible
c'est pas un sujet central dans
l'information médiatique
alors c'est pas un sujet central dans la
formation médiatique
probablement parce que
c'est vu comme un bien de consommation
avant d'être vu comme le déterminant de
ce qui fait notre monde
l'énergie je le redis on en parle
les carburants on en parle parce qu'on
les achète
on comprend pas que son camion il y
aurait pas de ville
sans camion il y a pas de ville pas de
parce que vous avez pas à manger vous
avez pas de bien de consommation vous
avez rien quoi pas de ville sans camion
donc on ne parle de l'énergie que sous
l'angle du prix ce qui est quand même
extrêmement réducteur et ce qui est très
court terme
d'une façon générale dans les médias
français il y a quand même il y a un
problème de qualification technique j'ai
envie de dire alors qui se qui évolue
doucement
mais les sujets très techniques sont
toujours des sujets avec lesquels les
médias français sont pas très à l'aise
peut-être que ça tient la formation des
journalistes qui n'est pas technique
donc du coup il faut qu'il compense par
de l'expérience sur le tas pour y
arriver et ça prend du temps
peut-être que c'est dû à l'organisation
des rédactions ou l'aristocratie c'est
de service politique qui justement ne
discute pas des visser des boulons parce
que l'intendance suivra enfin je sais
pas mais il y a une c'est clair que la
qualité de l'information elle est pas
terrible et le niveau d'information de
la population n'est pas très élevé la
bonne question c'est est-ce que c'est
très différent dans les autres pays
occidentaux j'ai pas la réponse à cette
question je serai étonné que ce soit
monstrueusement différent dans
l'essentiel des pays occidentaux on va
dire je pense qu'il y a quelques pays
qui sont quand même un peu plus mature
je pense que la Grande-Bretagne est un
pays dans lequel le débat est un peu
plus éclairé mais bon c'est un peu
mais d'une manière générale le degré de
compréhension du grand public et son
degré d'implication
dans ces débats et très faible quand on
dit qu'on fait des débats publics il
faut bien voir que ça concerne une toute
petite fraction de la population si je
prends par exemple les débats là qui
sont organisés en ce moment par la CNDP
c'est des débats je serai curieux de
voir à la fin du débat quelle est la
fraction de la population qui aura
entendu parler du débat
mais voilà mon expérience c'est que
c'est toujours des débats qui concernent
une toute petite fraction de la
population alors c'est pas
nécessairement une bonne nouvelle mais
en tout cas c'est une donnée du problème
en ce qui concerne les décideurs et les
élus alors là j'ai envie de dire que la
situation c'est différenciée sur les 10
dernières années je pense que le monde
civil a progressé plus vite que le monde
politique
et quand je vois
les débats qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui
dans le monde politique sur ce sujet
j'ai pas l'impression qu'on est beaucoup
bougé par rapport à il y a 10 ans
quand je vois le
il y a des décisions qui peuvent être
prises mais je veux dire globalement je
trouve que on n'a pas on n'a pas où il y
a 20 ans
quand dans le monde dans la société
civile
la conscience que les temps qui
s'annoncent risque pas être très simple
et la compréhension d'un certain nombre
de choses en ce qui concerne je parle là
plutôt des décideurs en ce qui concerne
à la fois le climat et l'énergie a quand
même un peu progressé
alors on va passer aux questions des
groupes alors pour Renaissance ce qui a
quelqu'un
non
[Musique]
pour le RN est-ce que quelqu'un a une
question
monsieur Tanguy
allez-y et merci monsieur le Président
bonjour
j'ai pas entendu votre
introduction j'ai répondu vos réponses
aux questions je vais me fonder sur les
travaux que j'ai lu de vous et les
nombreuses interviews que j'ai entendu
de vous notamment rebondir sur ce que
vous avez sur le pétrole bon alors à
notre modèle modeste échelle
effectivement nous aussi on essaie de
mettre le sujet du pétrole depuis plus
de 10 ans dans le débat public nous
avons et échoué même là en ce moment
vous avez parlé du gaz avec Poutine le
pétrole le fait même dans le dans les
ressources financières de la Russie sont
plus importantes que les que les
ressources financières liés au gaz et
pourtant même ça ça a échoué bon ça
reste on le voit bien aujourd'hui dans
les préoccupations des Français on a
encore vu avec la pénurie qu'on a subi
reste un sujet central et pourtant
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de solution
technique donc j'espère enfin l'une des
raisons de cette commission j'espère
c'est pas seulement de de critiquer pour
critiquer même si non s'en sortirait
bien c'est de de savoir ce qu'on fait
voilà et donc j'ai bien entendu vous
vous réflexions sur les moyens de
production
électrique électrogène alternatif mais
comment on fait voilà qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire pour le pétrole et pour
remplacer cette ce dont ce don de la
nature enfin ce dont empoisonné mais
enfin en tout cas techniquement ce don
qui a permis la société de consommation
et aussi l'amélioration des conditions
de plus grand nombre parce que bon pour
vous suivre régulièrement et le
l'impasse là pourri qu'on a dans le
débat public c'est le lien quand même
entre la hausse du niveau de vie et la
démocratie est quand même évident donc
tout le monde remet en cause visiblement
l'abaissement du niveau de vie comme une
une fatalité moi ce qui m'inquiète
beaucoup c'est que je pense que ce sera
lié à une baisse de niveau démocratie
des libertés publiques qui va avec donc
l'importance de trouver une solution à
ce qui est permis non pas
l'enrichissement des personnes mais
juste que leur vie soit plus douce plus
agréable et plus vivable nous procure
vivement donc vous avez fait beaucoup de
critiques et les entends c'est pas une
critique de la critique mais qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire vous à votre place
qu'est-ce que vous prendrez comme option
technique sachant le panel de
technologie la France
la réponse elle est alors la réponse
longue elle figure dans les travaux qui
ont été faits par le chiffre project sur
la façon de faire évoluer le parc de
bâtiments et la mobilité quand on
regarde où sont les usages du pétrole en
France aujourd'hui en fait on a trois
grandes on a trois grands usages en
[Musique]
usages importants on va dire il y a un
usage dans la mobilité l'essentiel du
pétrole va dans la mobilité des
marchandises et dans la mobilité des
personnes et paradoxalement on est plus
dépendant encore de la mobilité des
marchandises qui n'ont pas de jambes que
de la mobilité des personnes il y avait
il y a pas très longtemps j'avais fait
remarquer que si demain matin il y avait
une voiture sur trois seulement qui
était capable de rouler en France et
bien tout le monde violerait mais en
attendant on arriverait à s'organiser
quand même alors que si demain matin il
y a seulement un camion sur trois qui
roule en France on a un tout petit sujet
d'approvisionnement alimentaire donc là
il y a 30% des camions en France qui
transportent un truc qui se mange
donc le
donc le le pétrole il sert d'abord à ça
il sert ensuite un peu au chauffage et
enfin il sert un peu dans l'industrie et
dans l'industrie son usage le plus
précieux et comme matière première pour
faire de la chimie organique laquelle
Chili organique va se retrouver
absolument partout dans les vêtements
dans les bâtiments dans les détergents
dans et dans j'ai envie de dire les
biens intermédiaires qui servent à tout
plein l'industrie à Laval
les options pour remplacer le pétrole
sont pas les mêmes en fonction de ce
qu'on regarde alors en ce qui concerne
la mobilité au chiffre project on a fait
un certain nombre et un certain nombre
de morceaux du plan de transformation de
l'économie française qui porte là dessus
on a à la fois analysé la mobilité
longue distance
dont la mobilité aérienne a fait l'objet
d'un rapport à part la mobilité du
quotidien la mobilité des marchandises
donc on a regardé tout ça si je fais
cours dans les conclusions il va falloir
faire avec moins de voitures parce que
l'énergie c'est un demi de MV2 donc
quand on déplace une virgule 5 tonnes de
métal bah ma foi en a besoin d'une
certaine quantité d'énergie et si on a
plus le pétrole les énergies
alternatives que ce soit
l'électrification les agro-carburants
etc ne permettront pas de conserver en
France 40 millions de véhicules
particuliers comme on les a aujourd'hui
c'est pas nécessairement un drame
simplement il faut pouvoir s'organiser
en conséquence non c'est pas
nécessairement un drame et de toute
façon on va devoir faire avec donc je
confère ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure à
la question sur la croissance donc après
on peut taper du pied se rouler par
terre mais ça changera strictement rien
donc
ça c'est votre métier si vous me le
posez si vous le prenez comme ça donc je
le redis moi je suis là pour vous faire
part de fait physique l'effet physique
c'est qu'on va en avoir moins et que
avec moins on aura moins de voitures
alors après on peut s'organiser encore
une fois en faisant en sorte que ce soit
pas un drame où on peut ne rien faire et
si on ne fait rien à ce moment ça sera
un drame c'est ça qui va se passer en
fait c'est à dire que les au fur et à
mesure que on sera privé il y a des gens
qui vont être sortis du jeu sans avoir
vu le couvenir à l'avance c'est
exactement ça qui va se passer
si on veut s'organiser pour que ce soit
un drame ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
développe dans ce pays des transports en
commun pas nécessairement des transports
lourds de reste il faut faire aussi des
bus et des autocars il faut faire du
covoiturage il faut faire des modes
actifs alors qu'ils sont
particulièrement pertinents en ville et
en et en périphérie de ville danse c'est
évidemment beaucoup moins facile de se
balader à vélo sur 30 bornes quand on
est loin de tout
pardon
voilà
oui mais il y a plein d'endroits où on
n'est pas loin de tout donc il y a plein
d'endroits où on peut quand même
s'organiser pour faire autrement et
il va falloir également s'occuper du
transport des marchandises et là c'est
exactement pareil il y a une partie du
fret qu'on peut électrifier sur
autoroute ou sur grand axe en hybridant
les camions et en les électrifiant il y
a une partie du fret qu'on peut basculer
sur le ferroviaire il y a une partie du
fret qu'il faut arrêter de déplacer je
pense pas aujourd'hui que si aujourd'hui
on arrêtait les livraisons sous 24
heures par un Gafa que je nommerai pas
je sais pas si la population suiciderait
pas complètement persuadé donc il y a un
certain nombre de choses on peut tout
simplement y renoncer sans que ce soit
dramatique ce qui va être ennuyeux c'est
pour les gens qui travaillent donc en
fait si on doit renoncer à une activité
la vraie question c'est pas tant le
drame pour le consommateur parce qu'il y
a un certain nombre de choses pour
lequel je pense qu'on y arrivera encore
à peu près c'est le drame pour les gens
qui y travaillent donc en fait il faut
planifier ce genre de truc et il faut se
le faire avec un préavis suffisant pour
que les gens puissent trouver quelque
chose qui les intéresse ailleurs en ce
qui concerne le transport aérien le
transport aérien est né avec le pétrole
et Morat avec le pétrole là quand on
regarde les alternatives technologiques
il y en a pas une qui à l'échelle de
façon raisonnable si on devait je vais
juste vous donner un exemple sur les
agrocarburants le pétrole aujourd'hui
consomme 8% du pétrole mondial l'avion
pardon consomme 8% du pétrole mondial
si je transformais en agrocarburant les
quatre premières cultures végétales dans
le monde qui sont le maïs le riz le blé
et le soja intégralement en
agrocarburant intégralement la gros
carburant
j'aurais en gros un quart du pétrole
mondial c'est-à-dire que j'aurais trois
fois ce que consomme l'aérien
donc on oublie les agro-carburants pour
promener des riches en avion
on oublie quoi donc le donc une partie
du transport aérien va se contracter
voilà c'est on va faire avec mais c'est
pas nécessairement un drame voilà on
fera autrement et ces choses là encore
une fois moins on les anticipe
et plus ça sera désagréable donc la
technologie elle va nous permettre
d'amortir un certain nombre de
d'évolution elle va nous permettre de
trouver d'autres choses un vélo
électrique c'est un objet technologique
c'est un objet technologique vous avez
aujourd'hui un certain nombre
d'équipementiers en France qui ont
commencé à se mettre à des pièces pour
les vélos électriques si on passe de
voiture importée à des vélos électriques
fabriqués en France on peut à la fois
avoir de la sobriété dans les
déplacements et gagner en emploi
en France donc il faut pas voir
nécessairement le changement de mode de
déplacement comme quelque chose qui est
nécessairement dramatique à chaque fois
il y a des choses intéressantes et des
choses qui sont moins et il faut essayer
de faire le tri de telle sorte que
l'option soit la plus intéressante
possible mais de toute façon les limites
de l'exercice je le redis c'est que du
pétrole on va en avoir de moins en moins
et que c'est un truc qui est tellement
extraordinaire
en termes physiques j'ai envie de dire
que les options pour le remplacer on en
aura pas à l'échelle voilà c'est comme
ça encore une fois je suis pas sûr que
ce soit très grave si on s'organise bien
pardon j'ai pas couvert les bâtiments
les bâtiments il faut remplacer le les
chaudières à fuel par des pompes à
chaleur en ayant isolé les bâtiments
voilà et à ce moment on tombe sur des
problèmes pratiques qui sont avoir
suffisamment d'artisans avoir
suffisamment de pompe à chaleur fabriqué
en France et avoir une production
électrique suffisante voilà c'est on
tombe sur les problèmes pratiques de
cette nature
alors ce que je vous propose on va
essayer de prendre des séries de 3
questions parce que sinon on arrive à
pas à tenir le
timing et je reprends l'ordre des
groupes donc Madame manier millefort
pendant 6 mois
merci monsieur le Président pas
d'inquiétude
merci Monsieur Jean-Côme ici alors moi
j'ai une question sur les besoins de
chaleur en France ça représente je crois
50% à peu près de l'énergie qu'on
consomme en France l'énergie finale
pourquoi est-ce que les sujets des NR
thermique sont si mal investis en France
vous avez évoqué le prisme électrique
mais enfin il y a peut-être pas que ça
donc pourquoi est-ce que ça bloque
autant deuxième question
sur l'évolution des consommations
énergétiques on a tendance à voir que
plus on augmente la production plus on
augmente les consommations est-ce qu'à
un moment donné il est possible de
revenir en arrière sur un certain nombre
de technologie inflationniste
énergétique pour retrouver
finalement des des consommations qui
pour répondre à peu près en même d'usage
consomme moins d'énergie on voit par
exemple les véhicules ils viennent de
plus en plus gros de plus en plus
importants finalement ils servent le
même usage quand ils sont finalement
plus petits moins moins lourd et ils
font le même
service rendu donc est-ce qu'on peut
revenir aux usages pour poser la
question du besoin énergétique en France
et du coup poser la question de la
sobriété de cet angle là et ma dernière
question c'est vous avez parlé du
consensus qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
créer dans la population sur une
stratégie énergétique globale qui
dépasserait les alternances politiques
mais en l'occurrence
les grandes oppositions de dissensus
qu'on a pu avoir c'était celle des ENR
et du nucléaire pendant longtemps et
pour le coup vous y avez un peu
contribué à créer du dissensus donc
comment est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on dépasse
ce dissensus et est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez réglé vos dissensus avec les
MNR
alors Monsieur pardon on va prendre
plusieurs questions monsieur Lenet
alors
il y avait la chaleur
sobriété et le consensus
alors attendez on va vous trouver ça
du coup monsieur monsieur lainet
merci monsieur le Président j'attendais
que Monsieur Jean-Côme ici est terminé
parce que j'ai un certain nombre de
questions
merci Merci à VOUS déjà pour l'exposé
les premières réponses aux questions je
partage avec vous des objectifs assez
ambitieux de sobriété je crois qu'on
s'en sortira pas si on fixe pas des
objectifs et si on effectivement on
n'arrive pas à les discuter avec les
gens la sobriété doit faire aussi
l'objet de consensus dans la population
bon à certains nombre de questions assez
précises sur le nucléaire et sur les
renouvelables pour finir sur le
nucléaire on a le parc nucléaire
actuellement confronté au problème des
corrosion sont contraintes est-ce que
vous avez des indications techniques sur
le sujet la possibilité de les surmonter
sur les EPR alors vous vous avez parlé
des des centrales de 4e génération mais
actuellement ce qui est en projet c'est
les EPR 2 on a le problème de
Flamanville qui est toujours pas mis en
service et qui doit être mis en service
en 2023 mais je sais plus quel est le
terme mais de manière en mode dégradée
voilà et sur les EPR 2 ailleurs dans le
monde à tihan par exemple on a entendu
parler des SMS est-ce qu'elle est votre
avis là dessus il me semble que le
nucléaire pose aussi un problème de
délai parce que entre le moment où on
prend la décision ensuite la
construction en fait est-ce que c'est
vraiment raisonnable de Paris et
là-dessus pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique question
suivante c'est vous avez évoqué le
problème de sécheresse et du déficit
d'eau et du réchauffement de l'eau c'est
un souci pour refroidir les réacteurs
quel est votre avis là-dessus la
question du coût du nucléaire aussi
parce que je pense qu'il est pas à
l'heure actuelle il est pas payé à son à
son prix réel EDF et endetté à hauteur
de 60 milliards si on investit dans le
nucléaire est-ce qu'il va rester de
l'argent pour investir dans dans les EnR
7e question sur la question des déchets
nucléaires qui est quand même pas une
petite question qu'on peut balayer d'un
revers de main et pour terminer puisque
il y a quand même une un sujet qui est
le pilotable
dans les énergies renouvelables on a le
biogaz et on a l'hydrogène alors
l'hydrogène qu'il faut d'abord produire
effectivement avec de l'électricité mais
voilà quel est votre avis là-dessus
merci
du coup vu la masse de questions on va
vous laisser répondre et puis on
reprendra le cycle des questions après
il y a un plateau repas qui est prévu
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on parle peu de
la chaleur einr dans ce pays je vais
tenter une hypothèse
mon hypothèse elle est liée au Grenelle
au moment où a eu lieu le Grenelle de
l'environnement Sarkozy avait dit on ne
parlera pas de nucléaire
du coup les associations
anti-nucléaires n'ont pas parlé de
nucléaire mais quand elles ont parlé de
renouvelables elles ont essentiellement
parlé de renouvelables électriques
puisque quand on est tenté nucléaire on
est essentiellement intéressés par les
renouvelables électriques et donc je il
y a eu un gros accent qui a été mis
dessus à l'époque et le sujet était pas
tant climat puisque remplacer une
énergie bas carbone par une autre
énergie bas carbone ça change pas grand
chose du point de vue du climat à ce
moment l'accent était sans le dire mais
quand même une motivation anti-nucléaire
donc je moi j'ai envie de j'ai envie de
le et ça s'inscrit dans une opposition
du reste ça sera votre troisième
question qui est plus ancienne et qui
était aussi ma remarque tout à l'heure
sur le débat public en disant que
l'opposition pour enfin le nucléaire et
l'élément pivot en général des débats
publics sur l'énergie beaucoup plus que
les hydrocarbures et donc ça a beaucoup
structuré y compris le développement des
EnR pour moi ça c'est ça vient ça vient
de ça
encore aujourd'hui alors je sais pas bon
les derniers informations que j'avais
daté de 2018 ou 2019 en 2018 ou 2019
vous aviez quand même plus de deux tiers
des Français qui pensaient que le
nucléaire contribue significativement
aux émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
à mon avis c'est une conséquence directe
de ce débat et du fait que on a très
longtemps opposé ENR au nucléaire
au lieu de mettre ça dans une même
famille d'énergie bas carbone ce qui
aura évidemment changé différemment sur
lesquels on peut être d'accord ou pas
d'accord sur la répartition c'est un
autre sujet ce qui aurait changé la
perception du public
c'est alors là pour le coup c'est très
différent dans d'autres pays européens
il y a beaucoup de d'autres pays
européens mais en général quand la
chaleur renouvelable a fait l'objet de
politique de promotion ancienne c'est
que le pays avait par ailleurs un
potentiel important donc dans les pays
du Nord qui ont des gisements forestiers
très importants rapportés à la
population la chaleur renouvelable fait
l'objet de défauts depuis longtemps
quand vous êtes en Islande qui a la
population qui est un peu plus peuplée
que Boulogne-Billancourt mais pas
beaucoup et que vous avez le potentiel
géothermique que vous avez c'est
pareil il y a une promotion de la
chaleur renouvelable qui est faite
depuis longtemps il y a probablement
aussi peut-être qu'il y a aussi en
France cet élément qui a joué c'est à
dire que la chaleur renouvelable elle
n'avait pas un potentiel très important
quand elle avait un potentiel important
dans certaines régions de France pensant
en particulier au Dôme à ce moment elle
a fait l'objet d'une promotion aussi
parce que les chauffe-eau solaires sont
beaucoup sont raisonnablement répandues
dans les territoires d'outre-mer
comment est-ce que on fait en sorte de
limiter les usages dans le décidant
rien ne nous empêche en théorie de
militer en enfin à l'Europe puisque
maintenant c'est l'Europe qui a la
compétence pour que on limite le poids
des véhicules neufs vendus c'est il y a
pas de limite physique et ça il y a
juste une affaire de volonté
il faut bien voir que quand on augmente
les usages en fait ça augmente
l'activité économique sous-jacente et
quand on a comme prisme de lecture
premier quoi qu'on fasse le prisme
économique en fait on va assez rarement
chercher à limiter les usages même quand
il s'agit de fumer quand il s'agit de
manger et de boire trop sucré ou trop
gras etc on va pas limiter les usages on
en fait de la pub donc en fait dès lors
qu'on prend les activités sous l'angle
économique
il y a un mécanisme qui se met en route
naturellement qui est de pousser à
l'inflation des usages parce que c'est
ça qui pousse à l'inflation de
l'activité
donc ça veut dire que si on veut en
sortir
ça renvoie au débat qu'on a eu tout à
l'heure il faut qu'on accepte de changer
la hiérarchie des indicateurs
ce qui est pas simple mais ça passera
par là
est-ce que je suis sorti du dissensus
j'ai toujours la même opinion en ce qui
concerne la pertinence de remplacer du
nucléaire par des EMR ça j'ai toujours
dit que c'était un truc qui servait à
rien et je continue à penser que ça sert
à rien
après délibérément bien délibérément je
pense que ça sert à rien et que ça a été
une perte de temps et d'argent
maintenant est-ce que dans le cas dans
lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui c'est
stupide de faire des ENR non et ça
dépend lesquels et ça dépend pourquoi
faire donc je continue à penser qu'il
faut raisonner de manière pragmatique et
différenciée et qu'il ne faut pas ni
nucléaire ni NR de tous les brevets de
vertus encore une fois toutes les
énergies ont des avantages et des
inconvénients et ce que j'espère c'est
de il me semble que la bonne situation
est celle dans laquelle on juge sur
pièces
c'est évidemment pas la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes le plus souvent
mais c'est vers ça qu'il faut essayer de
tendre
alors
est-ce que j'ai des informations sur la
corrosion sous contrainte oui il y a des
informations publiques il y a les
wandowski qui a fait une audition à
l'OPEX pas plus tard qui a quelques
jours dans laquelle il a repris il a
fait quelque chose d'assez complet je
sais pas si vous l'avez vu passer bah je
voulais aller voir parce que c'est assez
complet et en particulier
les indications il fournit un certain
nombre d'indications techniques
sur le sur la chose
qu'est-ce que je pense de l'EPR 2 et des
SMR alors je pense que le Pr était un
truc qui était trop compliqué parce que
on a cherché à faire plaisir à la fois
aux Français et aux Allemands parce que
je vous rappelle que c'est un réacteur
de conception franco-allemande
depuis l'origine la SN n'a jamais eu à
sa charge je dis pas qu'il faut qu'elle
l'aime mais je rappelle juste n'a jamais
eu à sa charge de faire un arbitrage
coup bénéfice sur les mesures de sûreté
qu'elle est chargée de mettre en oeuvre
dit autrement son seul prisme de lecture
c'est il faut que ce soit sûr mais si le
fait que ce soit trop sûr engendre un
risque de défaut d'approvisionnement qui
lui-même pourrait avoir des conséquences
extrêmement délétères c'est hors de son
mandat c'est hors de son champ
or il me semble que on ne pourra pas
faire l'économie dans un monde qui va
lui-même être en économie de moyens de
se poser ce genre de questions il me
semble qu'à l'avenir on va
nécessairement être obligé de se poser
la question de savoir jusqu'où est-ce
qu'on accepte de ne pas disposer à temps
mais c'est vrai pour n'importe quoi
c'est aussi vrai pour les éoliennes qui
emmerdent un certain nombre de gens et
pour lesquels on se dit bah ils nous ont
Kikine on va quand même en faire parce
que c'est nécessaire donc c'est vrai
d'une façon plus large on va
nécessairement être obligé de revoir
l'arbitrage avantage inconvénient à
l'aune d'un monde dans lequel on est un
peu dans une course contre-la-montre et
dans lequel on va être en économie
forcée de moyens de façon croissante de
façon croissante il va c'est dans ce
cadre là qui va falloir raisonner ce qui
est un cadre évidemment beaucoup moins
confortable que le cadre dans lequel on
raisonnait jusqu'à maintenant qui est un
cadre dans lequel on se dit on a le
temps
et on a par ailleurs pas d'effet
d'éviction puisque dans un monde en
croissance et où on n'est pas en pénurie
de moyens on peut courir plein de livres
à la fois dans un monde dans lequel on
n'est pas en croissance si on court le
mauvais c'est qu'on court pas le bon et
là on a un effet d'éviction dont on paye
le prix directement
donc dans ce monde là est-ce que il faut
faire un nucléaire aussi sur entre
guillemets ou exactement aussi complexe
plutôt que sur que celui qu'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est pas évident est-ce
qu'il faut faire que des EPR 2 pour
remplacer le parc actuel je ne le crois
pas personnellement
j'ai envie de dire le la solution qui
aurait ma préférence
c'est de mettre le paquet sur le
développement de la quatrième génération
parce que je pense que aujourd'hui on
est à 15 ans de pouvoir disposer si on
se met entre guillemets en économie de
guerre qui est un terme que j'utilise
parfois
on est à 15 ans de pouvoir disposer de
modèles déployables
et à ce moment on fait la jonction avec
des EPR le temps de pouvoir commencer à
déployer de la quatrième génération
mais on en fait pas plus que ça voilà
c'est pas une option aujourd'hui qui est
sur la table
et dans l'intervalle c'est évident que
aujourd'hui la seule option qui reste
donc aux Français de décider quelque
part si on veut plus d'électricité même
si elle est pas pilotable c'est de
rajouter des moyens ENR dans les 10 à 15
ans qui viennent il y a pas il y a rien
d'autre à faire parce que ça va quand
même plus vite de rajouter une éolienne
que de rajouter un réacteur ce qui avec
les EnR la difficulté est dans le
système donc elle est pas dans l'objet
faire une éolienne c'est pas compliqué
par contre faire un système qui repose
majoritairement sur des sources non
pilotables ça c'est tellement complexe
que personnellement je pense que on va
avoir beaucoup de mal à y arriver
mais on peut en rajouter un peu ça c'est
clair et par ailleurs il y a un scénario
que j'ai trouvé assez malin qui a été
publié il y a pas très longtemps par une
association qui s'appelle voie du
nucléaire
dans lequel la proposition c'est de
construire dans les décennies qui
viennent à la fois tant qu'on n'est pas
capable de faire la jonction avec du
nucléaire de 4e génération et du
nucléaire de 3e pour lui-même faire la
jonction c'est de développer des moyens
enr
et des steps de construire des steps en
France voilà je trouve que c'est ça se
regarde il faut regarder ça d'un peu
près je trouve que c'est pas
il y a quelque chose de séduisant dans
cette approche alors je n'ai pas regardé
je l'ai pas regardé sur toutes les
coutures je n'ai pas etc mais je trouve
que c'est quelque chose qui est pas
inintéressant et ce que disent alors ça
ça vous plaira peut-être moins mais ce
que dit c'est une fois que on est
capable de déployer du nucléaire de 4e
génération et qu'on retombe sur des
choses qui sont pilotables compactes etc
à ce moment les éoliennes qu'on a
construit une fois bon on l'a construit
pas une deuxième c'est à dire qu'une
fois qu'on a la plus besoin au bout de
30 ans on les on les déconstruit puis on
s'arrête là
ça se regarde je trouve que c'est pas
inintéressant comme
comme scénario
qu'est-ce que je pense des SMS si c'est
small ça sera small donc je pense que
c'est pas quelque chose qui va
significativement changer la donne
en fait ça peut être très intéressant
pour les régions insulaires
qui aujourd'hui dépendent de
l'électricité au fioul ou de
l'électricité au charbon donc ça peut
être intéressant pour eux
alors après il y avait tout un tas de
trucs sur le nucléaire allez les délais
bon je pense que j'ai répondu voilà
sécheresse c'est un problème de
production c'est pas un problème de
sûreté en fait comme vous le savez
probablement quand on met un réacteur à
l'arrêt parce que pour Dieu c'est quelle
raison vous avez besoin pour le
maintenir en conditions froides d'un
millième de l'eau dont vous avez besoin
en fonctionnement normal donc si jamais
vous avez plus assez d'eau bah le risque
que vous courez c'est le défaut de
production mais vous courrez pas un
risque de pour la sûreté alors le risque
en défaut de production il existe pour
tous les modes qui dépendent de l'eau
donc il existe pour les centrales
nucléaires il existe pour les centrales
thermiques alors accessoirement on en
veut plus non plus il existe aussi pour
l'hydroélectricité j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure
voilà il existe une anecdote ridicule
une anecdote marrante je sais pas si
vous le savez mais la plus grosse
centrale nucléaire américaine fonctionne
sans mer et sans rivière elle fonctionne
avec les eaux usées d'une ville donc ce
qui lui sert de source froide c'est les
eaux usées d'une ville
la question du coût alors la question du
coût du nucléaire et pour moi
essentiellement une une question de
cadre de marché
vous savez vous avez probablement
entendu parler du coût du mégawattheure
de la centrale de inclipoint qui va
sortir un peu plus de 100 livres
c'est-à-dire quelque chose entre 100 et
150 euros de mémoire
j'ai fait un petit calcul et en fait si
le financement de cette centrale avait
été fait avec de l'argent disponible à
2% par an et non pas avec de l'argent
disponible à 10% par an comme c'est le
cas dans le cadre de marché aujourd'hui
ou les acteurs prennent leur risque etc
la même centrale aurait produit des
mégawatt-heure aux alentours de 50 euros
donc en fait le vrai sujet du coût du
nucléaire pour moi c'est les structures
de financement et la structure de
financement dépend essentiellement du
fait que ça soit mis dans un cadre
public ou pas donc je vais le dire
autrement le nucléaire pour moi n'a rien
à faire dans un cas de privé c'est pas
récent une activité qui est régalienne
qui relève de l'État et qui doit accéder
à des financements qui sont ceux de
l'État
mais
j'ai le même raisonnement pour les EnR
je fais partie des gens qui considèrent
que d'avoir fourni des produits
financiers à 15% de rendement sur
capitaux investi sur les premiers
panneaux solaires c'était quelque chose
qui n'aurait jamais dû exister
la question des déchets alors c'est une
question
qui est très important dans le débat
public c'est à dire quand on regarde de
quoi les gens ont peur
quand il s'agit du nucléaire les déchets
c'est quelque chose qui arrive assez
haut dans l'ordre de priorité et alors
c'est quelque chose qui
pour moi
n'est pas du tout raccord avec la
hiérarchie des nuisances quand on
regarde tout ce qu'on bazarde dans
l'environnement c'est-à-dire que quand
on regarde tout ce qu'on bazarde dans
l'environnement je le CO2 les
phytosanitaires les particules fines etc
en fait les déchets nucléaires pour moi
j'aurais peut-être faire sauter en l'air
quelques personnes dans cette salle mais
c'est vraiment du deuxième ordre enfin
c'est c'est tout petit il y en a
quelques-uns alors évidemment c'est des
franges saloperies mais il y en a pas
beaucoup c'est confiné etc et de très
loin l'option préférentielle c'est de
les mettre dans un trou et de les
oublier
c'est exactement ce que les Suédois ont
décidé de faire je considère que le
retraitement est une bonne idée parce
que ça permet de concentrer le volume
qui a stocké derrière de façon très
importante
et puis ça permet de récupérer
un certain nombre de choses qui sont
récupérables dans les assemblages usées
par contre
il me semble que le et la réversibilité
du stockage je sais qu'il y a des gens
qui tiennent beaucoup personnellement ça
me semble pas crucial il y a un stockage
non réversible qui s'est fait de façon
tout à fait naturel il y a 2 milliards
d'années dans une mine d'uranium au
Gabon à auclos ou des réacteurs sont
apparus spontanément il y a le détail
dans quelques-uns de mes ouvrages si ça
je peux vous donner les références ça
vous amuse et donc les déchets qui ont
été produits à l'époque c'est à dire des
produits de fission qui ont été produits
à l'époque en fait ont très peu migré
par rapport à l'endroit où ils ont été
formés et c'était il y a 2 milliards
d'années donc je suis pas du tout
inquiet quand au fait que si on les met
dans une poussée dans une couche
géologique profonde on est capable de
mettre du pétrole et du gaz sous
pression qui va rester là pendant des
millions d'années et pourtant c'est
fluide et c'est à haute pression donc
dans une couche géologique appropriée on
peut très bien mettre quelque chose de
solide c'est-à-dire des colis vitrifiés
et pas être très inquiet sur le fait que
tel Zébulon ça va nous sauter la figure
50 ans derrière dernière chose qu'il
faut savoir sur les déchets c'est que
les produits de fission au bout de
quelques siècles sont revenus au niveau
de radioactivité de l'uranium initial
au bout de quelques siècles oui mais
enfin c'est moins que Notre Dame bon
qui est à l'air libre
qui est
à l'air libre qui est donc qui est
beaucoup plus agressé qui est beaucoup
voilà donc c'est non mais c'est dire
quelques voilà
c'est pour dire on souvent le chiffre de
100000 ans est mis en avant en fait il
faut voir que la partie la plus
radiotoxique de ce qu'on produit ça vit
pas du tout cette durée là c'est
beaucoup plus court
enfin qu'est-ce que je pense du biogaz
et de l'hydrogène alors le biogaz c'est
quelque chose qui de mon point de vue
est intéressant pour des usages de niche
alors le biogaz est une est une énergie
dérivée de la biomasse donc faire ce
qu'on fait les Allemands c'est-à-dire
faire des cultures dédiées pour faire
des grandes quantités de biogaz et
quelque chose qui me paraît pas du tout
pertinent
par contre faire du biogaz avec des
déchets agricoles ou avec des
couvertures intermédiaires et ensuite
s'en servir prioritairement pour
remplacer les combustibles fossiles de
la mécanisation agricole ça c'est
quelque chose qui me paraît tout à fait
pertinent dans le plan de transformation
de l'économie française on propose
déconstruire le réseau de gaz en France
puisqu'on propose de se passer de gaz
tout court qui est essentiellement
fossile aujourd'hui donc du coup
l'injection dans le réseau devient un
peu moins intéressantes et enfin la
production électrique elle peut
éventuellement être intéressante à
partir du moment où on s'en sert pour
remplacer le gaz dans les usages d'hyper
fin de dans les turbines quoi dans des
usages d'hyperpointes mais à ce moment
c'est plus tellement le même genre
d'installation parce qu'il faut des
grosses installations
histoire d'avoir des quantités de gaz
qui sont pas complètement ridicules
l'hydrogène pour stocker de la
production électrique intermittente le
rendement de chaîne est extrêmement
mauvais il est de l'ordre du car c'est à
dire que vous perdez 75% de l'énergie
électrique initiale dans le donc il vaut
mieux si on veut absolument stocker de
l'électricité
faire des stations de pompage voilà
reste à convaincre quelques habitants de
Savoie que on va noyer les vallées avec
l'eau du lac Léman
merci bien on reprend une le tour des
groupes monsieur bolo
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur joncovici je voudrais revenir
sur deux points que vous avez évoqué
avec nous le premier c'est l'accès aux
métaux qui conditionne notre
indépendance énergétique et ensuite le
deuxième point c'est la disponibilité
des ressources qui est un facteur
limitant d'une économie mais une
économie ça produit aussi des déchets ou
des objets en fin de vie qui ont une
valeur selon le principe de l'économie
circulaire nous évoquait l'énergie plus
importante nécessaire pour extraire des
métaux à la teneur réduite dans les
mines cette même quantité d'énergie pour
être utilisée pour recycler les métaux
qui se prêtent d'ailleurs plutôt bien au
recyclage donc la question est très
simple quel est votre analyse de
l'économie circulaire
alors madame matistel
oui merci monsieur le Président
merci beaucoup pour toutes les réponses
fournies que vous avez apportées
d'ailleurs ça nous laisse assez peu de
questions maintenant
simplement revenir sur l'objet de notre
commission d'enquête c'est analyser
l'éventuelle perte de souveraineté ou
d'indépendance énergétique de la France
du coup vous nous expliquez comme
beaucoup d'autres qu'elle n'a jamais été
atteinte et
pour se servir des erreurs qu'aurai pu
être faites par le passé on a besoin de
de cette analyse et je crois que c'est
véritablement l'objet de de notre de
notre commission d'enquête où nous avez
expliqué que sur toutes les énergies
finalement l'indépendance la
souveraineté est inatteignable parce
qu'on dépend de toute façon d'un
matériau que ce soit pour l'éolien pour
les pompes à chaleur pour le pétrole
pour l'énergie nucléaire etc sur la
question de hydro il y a effectivement
le stress hydrique mais on a un certain
nombre d'études qui nous dit quand même
que la courbe de pluviométrie peut-être
très
accentué enfin très oui fluctuante mais
quand même les quantités peuvent être là
et l'hydroélectricité à cette capacité
de stockage et sa flexibilité qui peut
peut-être lui permettre d'avoir une
sortie alors je parle de la grosse
hydroélectricité et pas de la petite
dont vous avez parlé ou de la micro et
vous évoquez d'ailleurs la question des
steps qui dont certains nombre de
projets sont sur la table pas que dans
la vallée de la Savoie mais bien
ailleurs est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y
a une acceptabilité suffisante pour
aujourd'hui voir arriver une step dans
une vallée auquel qu'elle soit
et ses avantages de STEP c'est quand
même à la fois la flexibilité et la
question de la pointe
que l'on évoquait tout à l'heure sur le
le nucléaire bon vous avez largement
répondu à mon collègue donc je ne vais
pas y revenir et j'avais une deuxième
question qui était sur
sur
bah voilà je l'ai perdu mais ça me
reviendra probablement en tout cas sur
sur cette question ah oui la dernière
question c'était finalement si on écoute
vos propos on serait plutôt dans la
situation où il faut se poser la
question plutôt de savoir quelle est
l'énergie qu'il faut produire comment on
réorganise notre société pour infiner se
passer d'un certain nombre de
productions qu'on aura de toute façon
plus dans les années qui viennent donc
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on est à ce
stade de conscience des populations et
du monde politique évidemment
dans cette orientation là
alors on va encore prendre les questions
de Monsieur Alfandari et de Madame
lernos comme Monsieur Jean vaucovici
note tout
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
Monsieur Jean-Côme ici merci de vos
propos vous avez déjà répondu à une
large partie de ce que je voulais vous
demander mais bon sur le principe sur
l'hypothèse de base de faire moins et de
faire avec ce qu'on a déjà prélevé c'est
certain je dois avouer que j'aime bien
votre votre point sur la différence
entre l'indépendance et le confort il y
a probablement peut-être plus de
souveraineté du côté du confort que
l'indépendance qui est peut-être assez
illusoire sauf si on cherche des guerres
bon dans vos travaux vous l'avez
clairement dit on a à peu près plus
qu'une seule cartouche à tirer on avait
à 30 ans pour agir au niveau mondial
et ce qui est extrêmement difficile
c'est
c'est le phasage c'est très clairement
c'est d'arriver à voir la différence
entre ce qui est mature entre ce qui
sera est intéressant et deviendra mature
à terme et la manière dont on déploie
l'ensemble de ces solutions à travers le
temps
typiquement c'est ce que vous disiez sur
le réacteur de quatrième génération
j'étais avec des gens du nucléaire qui
me disaient 50 ans pour la 4e vous dites
si on décide et qu'on y met la volonté
15 ans donc voilà il y a la question de
combien de réacteurs on déploie quelle
génération en déploie pour quelle
jonction
il y a après dans vos travaux il y a je
sais qu'il y a des il y a des points un
peu
qui sont mis un peu de côté qui est
clairement l'identification de la
ressource par exemple on parlait des
déchets juste avant et d'économie
circulaire il y a des procédés de
gazéification sur une partie de choses
qui ne sont plus traitables mais en même
temps si on veut de diminuer les
produits pétroliers si on est sur
d'autres types de plastique est-ce qu'il
y a des plastiques qui sont circulaires
sur lequel on va trouver le même
potentiel hydrogène ou pas il y a le
problème donc des dimensions industriels
de ce qu'on va faire et puis toute la
question du programme
par exemple j'ai visité une société qui
fait de l'impression 3D et qui
aujourd'hui fait des faits des pièces
qui sont beaucoup moins lourdes
notamment pour le transport ferroviaire
sans perdre de matière il y a des gains
probablement à trouver par là et pareil
dans vos travaux vous vous l'esquissez
mais on prend pas trop en compte la
question de l'aménagement du territoire
dans les modes de vie qu'on va changer
il y a bien sûr des
usages comme marjols le disait qu'on
pourrait abandonner ou mais il y a aussi
la question de comment on occupe le
territoire et comment on vit dessus et
ça c'est c'est extrêmement difficile à
prendre en compte
et puis enfin je vais être un peu je
provoque pour tous les blancs on voit
bien que
ceux qui gagneront demain sont pas
forcément
ce qui perdront aujourd'hui qui a
l'accompagnement de ça et moi ça me pose
la question du salaire universel par
exemple
tu as l'air universelle dividende
universel enfin ce que
quel que soit le nom en tout cas quelque
chose ou qui qui vient clairement
accompagner les gens dans cette mutation
profonde qui va toucher nos systèmes
économiques nos systèmes sociaux nos
systèmes de production de déplacement et
d'habitat
oui merci
plusieurs questions et plusieurs
réactions aussi tout d'abord le chiffre
project et les travaux que vous avez
menés ont éclairé un certain nombre de
points importants notamment sur la
sobriété sur la de prendre de manière
globale les problématiques et vos propos
introductifs notamment sur avoir
l'économie comme donner sortante et non
pas entrante en fonction des ressources
dont on dispose
favorisent la réflexion un peu plus
approfondie et globale plutôt que de se
dire qu'il y a une solution
technologique qui va sauver tout notre
climat et nous préserver du
réchauffement climatique à venir et je
pense que l'accent n'est d'ailleurs pas
assez mis souvent y compris quand on
évoque votre nom souvent ce n'est pas
vos propos ou vos travaux sur la
sobriété la rénovation sur ce que vous
avez eu comme propos et qui sont dans
vos écrits aussi notamment vis-à-vis de
transport aérien ou là il n'y aura pas
de solutions techniques qui permettra de
continuer à se déplacer sur des longs
courts comme nous le faisons aujourd'hui
mais qu'il y a là dans vos écrits de
manière scientifique technique étayées
le fait qu'il faut envisager une autre
manière de vivre et une autre manière de
partager aussi les ressources qui me
semblent importantes sur lequel il
faudrait à mon sens mettre plus l'accent
je reviendrai sur vous avez évoqué
effectivement la question du consensus
et je pense que vous et votre nom
aujourd'hui évoque pas mal de dissensus
y compris par rapport aux écologistes
puisque
ils comptent dans les dans les travaux
et puis dans les propos que vous avez
tenu y compris sur la responsabilité qui
serait dû à l'accord électoraliste entre
le Parti socialiste et ma formation
politique et Europe Écologie Les Verts
ça serait là le début du mot des mots et
la de souveraineté en tout cas en
matière de nucléaire j'ai envie de dire
que pour le physicien que vous êtes dans
le réchauffement climatique et la lutte
qui nous rassemble toutes et tous en
tout cas dans les solutions qu'on essaye
d'y apporter et d'y trouver on sait très
bien que c'est les 15 prochaines années
qui sont cruciales puisque les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre s'accumulent
aujourd'hui et provoque donc des
réchauffement climatique qui va
s'amplifier or la solution qui semble
trouver la seule solution j'ai envie de
dire qu'ils sont trouvées la vraie grâce
à vos yeux qui est le nucléaire ne
pourra pas se déployer de manière
massive comme vous l'appelez de vos vœux
d'ici les 15 prochaines années
d'ailleurs vous évoquez sur les pendus
technologiques entre le Pr troisième
génération 4e génération on ne sait pas
exactement sur quelle technologie on
pourrait s'appuyer pour lancer d'un
point de vue massif vous dites vous-même
que c'est assez
utopique d'un point de vue de
réalisation parce que tout n'est pas al
dans ce sens là et donc j'ai quand même
une interrogation
réelle de savoir quand vous faites tous
ces travaux et alignez tous ces travaux
on voit bien que la fermeture de
Fessenheim aurait pu largement être
compensée si l'État français avait
réellement investi dans les énergies
renouvelables avec tenu ses objectifs et
compris en matière de sobriété que ça
soit dans les transports ou dans tous
les potentiels j'ai envie de dire non
activé dans la rénovation énergétique et
thermique on voit que ça serait dix fois
supérieur à ce que était la production
de Fessenheim et d'ailleurs les
responsables à ce moment-là que ça soit
RTE y compris au sein d'EDF avec fu
kushima qui est intervenu les
investissements étaient trop élevés dans
la sécurisation de la centrale de
Fessenheim pardon pour pouvoir la
maintenir ouverte et donc c'est là une
enfin j'ai une réelle interrogation
puisque tout semble conjugué pour vous
vers le nucléaire or il me semble que si
vous prenez les là où on en est les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui
vaut aujourd'hui éviter
ça ne paraît pas le plus logique y
compris en termes d'ingénierie
d'utilisation de métaux d'utilisation
d'importation ce qui peut aussi importer
l'uranium et je voudrais revenir aussi
puisque vous avez et vous êtes le
premier qui répond à la question ce que
nous avons posé la question de
nombreuses reprises sur la question du
réchauffement climatique et de la
sécheresse c'est à dire que tout les
centrales nucléaires sont construits à
proximité de cours d'eau on voit que cet
été en dehors des problèmes de corrosion
sous contrainte et du vieillissement du
parc actuel on voit que cet été on a
autorisé des dérogations aux droits pour
pouvoir rejeter de l'eau plus chaude
dans nos fleuves et qu'on va manquer de
plus en plus d'eau et je ne trouve pas
très sérieux alors que vos propos sont
très étayés et factuelles de dire que on
va utiliser l'eau des égouts qui par
ailleurs peut être relativement plus
chaude pour refroidir les réacteurs
nucléaires et puis on parle dans le
projet de loi d'accélération sur le
nucléaire et également de déroger aux
droits littoral notamment pour
construire des nouveaux réacteurs le
long des côtes or on voit là aussi que
le réchauffement climatique
va engendrer une hausse du niveau de la
mer et donc j'ai une vraie interrogation
sur un vrai regret j'ai envie de dire
c'est à dire que autant une grande
partie de vos travaux illustre et sont
importants et contribuent à l'évolution
des consciences et des actes y compris
dans le secteur privé parce qu'on ne
pourra pas
diminuer nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre sans accompagner et avoir le
secteur privé avec nous pour
s'interroger sur ce qu'on produit
pourquoi on le produit pour autant la
solution monomaniaque sur le nucléaire
me semble pour le coup créer du
dissensus alors qu'il nous faudrait un
consensus et pour le coup une vraie arme
de guerre pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique qui va plus sur
la sobriété la et les énergies
renouvelables et il y a des scénarios
qui comprennent tout cela et qui disent
aussi que c'est tout à fait faisable
vous faites le choix dans choisir un
autre mais voilà c'est ça mon
interrogation principale
la question est assez simple c'est à
dire que vous la question vous misez y
compris en termes de matériaux
disponible du cuivre etc vous dites les
énergies renouvelables sont trop
gourmandes pour cela et ne produisent
pas assez d'électrons vous dites qu'il y
a que le nucléaire qui peut faire ça or
vous hésitez vous-même entre les
différentes générations et vous dites
que les unr sont là que pour faire la
jonction or qu'est-ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui contre le réchauffement
climatique d'ici que le fait qu'on
puisse de manière hypothétique
construire de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires c'est à dire que même vous
vous n'avez pas d'informations ou de
propositions fiables sur quelle
génération vous avez parlé de l'uranium
235 et 238 et puis sur les propositions
en termes des ressources qui nous sont
dit souvenues notamment les ressources
en eau pour refroidir les réacteurs pas
non plus donc je ne comprends pas
quelque part malgré la richesse des
travaux et des propos pourquoi vous vous
entêtez sur cette unique voie du
nucléaire c'est ça ma question merci
beaucoup Monsieur Jean-Claude je voulais
y répondre je vous informe qu'avant je
prendrai une dernière série de questions
après parce que là comme ça on a fini le
tour des orateurs de groupe et on fera
une dernière série de questions j'ai
noté trois personnes encore
voilà je vous laisse la parole
alors
où est-ce que j'en étais dans
la première série de questions
concernant les métaux c'est ça c'est ça
alors quand on utilise le terme
d'économie circulaire en fait il y a une
petite méprise les atomes sont
recyclables l'énergie jamais
donc il faut bien voir que d'aller
récupérer des atomes là où ils sont
c'est ça l'économie circulaire j'ai des
atomes j'ai des molécules dans un
plastique un polymère et je vais essayer
de les récupérer pour en refaire un
polaire et bien ça c'est quelque chose
qui va quand même vous demander de
l'énergie
donc l'économie circulaire elle peut
être une solution
partielle ou importante à des questions
de disponibilité en matière en
ressources par contre ça va toujours
même l'économie circulaire avec une mise
en oeuvre enfin avec la disponibilité
d'une source énergétique dans certains
cas de figure l'énergie du recyclage
n'est pas considérablement inférieure à
l'énergie de la production de matières
primaire c'est notamment le cas du
papier c'est un exemple qui est bien
connu parce que des ancré le papier
c'est très énergivore et donc recycler
du papier ça permet assurément d'éviter
de couper des arbres puisque ça permet
d'éviter de
se permettre d'éviter de
s'approvisionner en fibres de bois
Vierge par contre sur le plan
strictement énergétique on gagne pas
énormément alors il y a des métaux qui
se recyclent facilement il y a des
métaux qui se recyclent beaucoup plus
difficiles les métaux qui se recyclent
facilement c'est les métaux qui sont peu
alliés par exemple le cuivre est un
métal qui s'utilise tel que il est
généralement pas allié on ne mélange pas
avec un autre métal ce recycle
extrêmement bien il est extrêmement
fortement recyclé vous avez d'autres
métaux qui s'utilisent en étant alliés
c'est-à-dire que il se trouve dans un
voyage et par exemple le manganèse est
un adjuvant de l'acier et vous n'avez
pas d'usage de manganèse pure enfin très
peu donc pour récupérer du manganèse en
fait il faut récupérer de l'acier
vous avez un certain nombre de petits
métaux qu'on appelle les Terrass qui
sont dans l'électronique par exemple qui
sont dilués à des concentrations qui
sont beaucoup trop faibles pour que ce
soit facile de les récupérer dans les
objets dans lesquels ils sont donc on
peut le faire mais avec des dépenses
énergétiques extrêmement importantes qui
peuvent être éventuellement supérieurs à
la dépense énergétique d'extraction de
la croûte terrestre donc il y a pas de
en fait il y a pas de réponse univoque
unique pardon à faire à la question que
vous posez là aussi il faut regarder en
fonction du métal etc il faut bien voir
que souvent pour les métaux qui valent
un peu cher et qui sont disponibles
quelque part sous forme un peu plus les
opérations de recyclage elles ont déjà
lieu
ça existe déjà par exemple tout ce qui
est chute dans l'usinage
en général c'est des métaux qui sont
recyclés c'est très rare que ces trucs
là soit perdus parce que ça c'est
quelque chose qui est facile à utiliser
facile à recycler etc les carcasses de
voitures c'est facile à recycler vous
les collez directement le convertisseur
par contre je le redis il y a d'autres
métaux c'est plus c'est plus difficile
de les c'est plus difficile de les
récupérer et il y a d'autres ressources
c'est plus difficile de les récupérer
aussi par exemple sur certains
plastiques des polymérisés des
plastiques pour les repolymériser
derrière ça peut être extrêmement
compliqué ça peut ne pas être possible
ça peut être très énergivore quand un
plastique est vieux il peut avoir été un
peu fatigué par le rayonnement
ultraviolet ou etc donc vous en refaites
pas l'usage initial c'est le fameux
exemple de la fourrure polaire qui est
faite avec des déchets de bouteilles
voilà donc il y a des choses à faire
c'est très difficile de faire une
réponse générale donc il faut regarder
au cas par cas et bien évidemment à
chaque fois qu'on peut gagner quelque
chose il faut le faire
après
il y avait une question sur les steps
c'est ça pourquoi est-ce que on fait pas
plus de STEP et quelle est
l'acceptabilité pour en faire
l'acceptabilité est faible comme pour à
chaque fois que vous avez l'intention de
construire quelque chose quelque part
donc
la réponse un peu plus générale que je
pourrais faire c'est que une des choses
sur lesquelles il faut arriver à se
mettre d'accord mais c'est difficile à
installer dans le débat politique par
jour même du débat politique c'est
l'idée que les temps qui viennent vont
ne se prêteront à aucune solution
parfaite
et que donc il va falloir accepter de
façon un peu partagée ce qu'on considère
être le plus faible inconvénient
ou l'idée qu'on se fait collectivement
du plus faible inconvénient
et évidemment ça sera toujours au
détriment des gens qui vont être
localement concernés par le plus faible
inconvénient donc si on décide le plus
faible inconvénient c'est de faire des
steps il y a quand même des gens qui
sont localement là où on va faire la
steppe qui vont pas être d'accord du
tout
du reste le droit a prévu depuis très
longtemps que on puisse passer par
dessus la tête de ces gens-là c'est les
procédures d'expropriation toute la
question elle est de savoir
collectivement où est-ce qu'on met le
moins de douleurs pour le plus de
bénéfices pour la collectivité c'est
toujours ça la question sachant qu'à un
moment il y a toujours des gens il va
falloir leur passer par dessus la tête
mais on a exactement le même problème
avec n'importe quel installation qui
demande de couler du béton quelque part
c'est
on a le problème on a le problème
partout
alors après il y avait tellement de
questions
il y a
noté plein de trucs
il y avait un sujet sur le progrès il y
avait un sujet sur l'aménagement du
territoire
et comment se passer d'un certain way
comment installer la sobriété
je reviens à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
le fait d'arriver à installer la
sobriété va avec le fait que il y a le
cadre physique dans lequel nous devons
raisonner à partir de maintenant ne nous
laisse plus toutes les options alors il
y a des domaines dans lequel on le sait
depuis longtemps par exemple si je bats
des bras dans cette pièce je vais pas
voler pour autant donc il y a des degrés
de liberté physique qu'on n'a pas on le
sait depuis longtemps ce qui est
beaucoup plus désagréable c'est de
d'accepter l'idée que des degrés de
physique qu'on a eu par exemple pour
quelques heures de Smic de monter dans
un engin qui va à 800 km/h et qui vous
emmène à 2000 km de là où vous êtes
on ne l'aura plus ça c'est quelque chose
qui est compliqué et ça va
nécessairement avec une notion un mot
que j'ai pas encore prononcé jusqu'à
maintenant qui est le mot de l'équité il
y a eu il y a pas longtemps comme vous
le savez probablement un petit débat sur
la question des jets privés alors quand
vous regardez ce que représente les jets
privés dans les émissions du pays où la
consommation de carburant du pays c'est
pas quelque chose qui est absolument
crucial
par contre c'est très emblématique d'un
luxe ostentatoire qui apparaît comme
insupportable à des gens qui vont devoir
faire des efforts sur des gestes qui
sont unitairement des gestes beaucoup
plus modestes et donc la question de la
sobriété pour moi elle est
fondamentalement associée à la question
1 de la maîtrise de son propre destin
donc ça renvoie à la question qui a été
posée par votre collègue urn tout à
l'heure sur comment est-ce qu'on fait
pour que des gens acceptent
de continuer à avoir l'impression d'être
maître de leur destin alors même qu'il y
a des choses qui physiquement lorsqu'on
plus accessibles donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui est évidemment une question
cruciale et ça va également avec l'idée
d'un arbitrage entre moins de liberté
aujourd'hui pour plus de liberté plus
tard parce que il y a aussi une question
qui a été posée sur la démocratie le
fait de pouvoir continuer du reste par
le même le reste de pouvoir continuer à
vivre en démocratie dans 20 ans
combien est-ce qu'on est prêt à payer
aujourd'hui
en kilomètres en voiture non effectué
pour conserver ça bon et c'est il y a
aussi ce genre de débat qui doivent être
installés dans la population et c'est
pas simple d'illustrer ce genre de débat
pour plein de raisons d'abord parce que
c'est pas simple d'illustrer le monde
dans 20 ans ou le ce qu'il pourrait être
dans les mauvais cas de figure dans 20
ans c'est un truc qui est compliqué et
c'est voilà mais c'est on est clairement
dans une discipline un peu nouvelle
qu'on va devoir apprendre que j'appelle
parfois la hiérarchie des renoncements
c'est-à-dire à quoi est-ce qu'on est
prêt à renoncer qu'est-ce qui va pas
être très coûteux finalement et
qu'est-ce qu'on a envie d'avoir en face
est-ce qu'on a envie d'avoir en face un
monde qui nous paraît plus assuré par
exemple est-ce qu'on gagne de l'espoir
est-ce qu'on gagne de la sérénité est-ce
qu'on gagne de la sécurité est-ce qu'on
gagne des trucs comme ça qui ont pas qui
ont pas de valeur économique stricto
sensu mais qui ont quand même une valeur
importante pour les individus puisqu'on
est sur le sur la question des
la question du confort psychologique et
la question du des valeurs en fait
voilà il y a pas de réponse miracle donc
là c'est clair qu'on va tâtonner un peu
très probablement mais il me semble
qu'il est important d'emmener le débat
sur ces terrains-là encore une fois qui
est la juste répartition de l'effort et
le fait par ailleurs de tenir un
discours adulte à la population et donc
de pas lui raconter trop de
carabistouille sur le cadre physique
dans lequel on va être obligé de
réfléchir
sur la question de l'aménagement du
territoire là je vous renvoie à la aux
travaux du shift récents qui s'appelle
stratégie de résilience des territoires
on a fait tout un tout un ensemble de
travaux là dessus et c'est clair que là
aussi il faut déconcentrer pour partie
l'initiative face aux problèmes mais il
faut la déconcentrer de manière
intelligente c'est-à-dire que la bonne
manière de déconcentrer l'initiative
c'est de mettre les gens en capacité de
comprendre pour moi c'est ça la première
étage de la fusée de façon et donc ça
passe comme pour les députés qui n'ont
pas été très assidus à la séance de
formation qui vient d'avoir lieu si j'ai
bien compris ça passe aussi pour les
élus locaux par le fait d'arriver à
comprendre ce qui se passe où sont leurs
marges de manœuvre et où est-ce que ils
doivent être fatalistes quelque part
même si c'est quelque chose qu'on n'aime
pas parce que ils vont se retrouver face
à plus fort que il va falloir qu'ils
composent avec une évolution qui va de
toute façon prendre place
les on a la première recommandation
stratégie de résilience des territoires
c'était de consacrer 1% des budgets
sachant qu'il y a 10% du budget pour
plein de communes qui vont être bouffées
par la hausse de l'énergie 1% du budget
à de l'acquisition de connaissances
c'est-à-dire soit de la formation des
élus des agents etc soit de la des
études Haddock qui permettent de
comprendre quelle est la situation de
départ avec les forces et les faiblesses
du territoire sur lequel on est et
comment est-ce qu'on confronte le
territoire un objectif national qui est
d'arriver à se passer progressivement
des hydrocarbures sous contrainte de
métaux d'espace de biomasse et tout un
tas d'autres trucs et de biodiversité
enfin bref tout un tas de trucs
voilà et sur la question du salaire
universel j'ai pas de réponse à vous
apporter
en France on est plus proche avec les
systèmes de solidarité que nous avons
que d'autres pays de cette notion
puisque on a déjà un certain nombre de
revenus garantis dans un certain nombre
de cas de figures on a une halo un
système de chômage qui est une très
bonne chose qui permet de faire face à
un certain nombre de situations où les
gens sont sans ressources
je n'ai pas les compétences j'ai pas
réfléchi à la question pour savoir si il
faut aller plus loin que ça et dans quel
sous quelle forme voilà donc là Joker si
j'ai envie de dire c'est un peu hors de
mon champ de compétences et j'ai pas
tellement de pas tellement de questions
alors après il y a une question
qui m'a été posée
enfin toute une série de questions
alors je vais quand même faire une
remarque vous avez commencé par me dire
vous parlez beaucoup de la sobriété on
vous voit pas assez là-dessus puis
ensuite vous m'avez traité de
monomaniaque du nucléaire enfin si je
parle beaucoup de la sobriété je peux
pas être un mot de maniaque du nucléaire
je parle nécessairement d'autres choses
que du nucléaire
alors si on m'entend que sur le
nucléaire cela il faut vous adresser au
journaliste il faut quand même savoir
oui oui je vais vous heurter une
anecdote
lors du lancement du monde sans fin
excellente BD que vous avez sûrement lu
j'ai été invité à la matinale de France
Inter ils avaient commencé par m'inviter
pour parler de nucléaire je leur ai dit
je n'irai pas j'en ai marre qu'on vient
de me chercher juste pour ce sujet je
n'irai pas bon et alors ils m'ont dit
est-ce que vous voulez venir parler de
votre BD j'ai dit ça je veux bien donc
en fait la raison pour laquelle je suis
mis en avant et là en ce moment là comme
je vous parle la semaine qui vient de se
passer j'ai dû refuser je crois combien
entre 5 et 10 invitations à les causer
du nucléaire dans la presse donc je sais
pas moi enfin c'est pas moi j'assume mes
opinions mais le fait que vous ayez une
presse qui adore et vous êtes bien payé
pour le savoir les trucs qui sont blancs
et noirs une fois qu'on vous a collé
dans une case c'est difficile d'en
sortir donc par ailleurs je je n'élutte
pas et je donc quand je suis sur un
plateau de télé et qui a 10 questions
dont une question sur le nucléaire je
réponds à la question sur le nucléaire
je veux dire je suis pas là pour veut
dire ah bah non celle-là je répondrai
pas j'ai pas envie allez donc voir
quelqu'un d'autre j'assume mais cela
étant aussi derrière le résumé c'est
qu'on retient que ça
je fais ce que je peux pour lutter
contre je ne maîtrise pas complètement
le processus donc je
m'exprime également
par d'autres canaux que la presse en
particulier je m'exprime tous les jours
sur LinkedIn et je ne parle pas tous les
jours de nucléaire si vous allez
regarder loin sans faut je m'exprime
également sur mon site personnel et je
ne parle pas que de nucléaire loin sans
faut donc et je m'exprime dans des
vidéos où je ne parle pas que de
nucléaire loin sans faute je suis
capable de faire un exposé d'une heure
et demie sur la situation énergétique et
climatique en prononçant le mot
nucléaire deux fois si je le prononce
donc voilà donc la seule chose que je
peux se dire c'est autant que faire ce
peu j'essaye de renvoyer les gens à mes
écrits et à mes euros primaires après la
presse de temps en temps vous la
maîtrisez pas complètement
encore une fois vous êtes bien placé
pour le savoir
bon après je sais pas si je voulais que
je réponde dans le détail à toutes les
autres trucs que vous avez
bon j'ai compris que vous aimiez pas
beaucoup de nucléaires
bon je sais pas si c'est la peine de
répondre en détail à tout
le sens de ma question est moi quand je
regarde Boutabout les éléments
rationnels et dont vous faites y compris
état dans un certain nombre d'écrits je
n'aboutis pas à la même conclusion c'est
pas une question d'idéologie c'est une
question de matbuta pou les choses et
c'est pour ça que je vous posais la
question sur les 15 années le
réchauffement climatique et sur
l'incertitude quelque part du
développement de la technologie qui que
vous mettez en exergue dans les options
et que vous défendez de fait et donc
c'est ça qui m'interroge réellement sur
pourquoi cette croyance quelque part
totale dans le fait que le nucléaire
sauverait le climat ce qui moi me paraît
antinomique mais c'est un peu ça voilà
c'était le sens de ma question ça
m'intéresse quand même votre réponse
alors si vous avez bien lu ce que j'ai
écrit et dit je n'ai jamais dit que le
nucléaire s'ouvrait le climat j'avais
j'ai toujours dit que le nucléaire
n'éviterait pas la décroissance toujours
j'ai toujours dit qu'il ne serait pas à
l'échelle pour remplacer les
combustibles fossiles toujours la seule
chose que je dis c'est que il fait
partie des amortisseurs de la
décroissance et dans cette catégorie là
je considère qu'il a un certain nombre
d'avantages physiques qui font que c'est
une bonne idée d'en faire autant qu'on
peut sachant qu'au temps qu'on peut ça
sera jamais des montagnes de toute façon
parce qu'il y a des limites temporelles
et de compétences sur son déploiement
qui font que de toute façon et j'ai
également écrit dans le premier livre
que j'ai écrit que l'énergie infinie
serait une absolue catastrophe je l'ai
écrit dès mon premier bouquin
l'explication on était tous transformés
en Superman vous voyez vous avez une
tête qui me plaît pas je fais exploser
cette salle enfin donc ça sera une
absolue catastrophe que on est tous de
l'énergie limitée qu'elle soit propre ou
sale n'est pas le sujet
donc j'ai mais par contre j'ai toujours
dit que il fallait dans un monde
imparfait et qui va malheureusement
l'aide de plus en plus
hiérarchiser nos possibilités d'action
et choisir en premier là où la balance
avantage inconvénient est la plus
intéressante or je fais partie des gens
qui ne croient pas pour dire que pour
des raisons physiques on ira jusqu'au
bout des scénarios de déploiement des
énergies renouvelables diffuses
électriques intermittentes donc les
trois adjectifs sont importants je pense
qu'on n'ira pas au bout parce que il
faudra c'est trop complexe comme système
il y a quatre conditions physiques sur
lesquelles l'aïeux et RTE ont dit qu'il
fallait arriver à franchir une barrière
que pour le moment on n'est pas arrivé à
franchir il y a un petit document qui a
été diffusé il y a un an et demi je
crois à peu près je sais pas si vous
l'avez vu qui listaient les quatre les
quatre conditions
il y a un sujet de stockage un sujet
d'ajustement fréquence il y a un sujet
de disponibilité
du il y a un sujet de
stockage inter saisonnier qui a un truc
très important alors bref il y a un
certain nombre de conditions et je pense
que on n'y arrivera pas donc à part or
le système nucléaire on y est déjà
arrivé une fois en France donc on a fait
la preuve qu'au moins on est arrivé une
fois donc c'est exactement l'image qu'on
utilise dans le dans le monde sans fin
ça fait partie des parachutes de secours
mais vous avez un parachute de secours
c'est un truc dont vous avez pas envie
de vous servir déjà vous avez du sauté
de l'avion parce qu'il était en flamme
et en plus le parachute dorsal mange ça
ne marche pas donc voilà mais c'est
quand même quelque chose qui à tout
prendre
présente des avantages supérieurs à ces
inconvénients voilà c'est ça mon opinion
en ayant bien regardé mon opinion sur le
nucléaire date d'une époque où je
n'avais pas touché un euro d'un acteur
de la filière nucléaire ça date du
moment où j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à
la question climatique en fait
chronologiquement j'ai regardé d'abord
le climat ensuite j'ai regardé le
nucléaire et ensuite j'ai regardé le
j'ai regardé chronologiquement dans ces
trois ordres là et j'ai donc j'ai à
l'époque j'étais pas j'avais zéro lien
économique avec ce monde là juste j'ai
été posé des tas de questions et tant
que j'avais pas compris j'ai continué à
les poser des questions bon et c'est de
cette époque là que je date que date ma
conviction que c'est une énergie qui est
à mettre du côté des solutions et pas du
côté des problèmes voilà mais c'est pas
parce que c'est à mettre du côté des
solutions que c'est miracles j'ai jamais
dit ça et je ne le dirai jamais
merci bien du coup on a encore deux
questions que je vous propose de faire
assez et ça m'évitera pas des
informations de sobriété j'insiste
là-dessus ça ne les évitera pas ça les
allège que je vous propose donc de merci
beaucoup monsieur Jean-Côme ici je vous
propose de faire les questions courtes
et synthétiques Madame brûlebois et
Monsieur Mazar
désir de vous écouter vous êtes une
figure incontournable de la
sobriété de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique vous parler
vrai vous parlez simple vous parlez
juste et vous plaisez beaucoup aux jeux
aux jeux de générations votre chaîne de
YouTube compte 220 000 abonnés votre
facebook 185000 lignes de kind 600 mille
abonnés pardon
voilà donc moi ce qui m'inquiète
voyez-vous c'est c'est ce numérique qui
est sur la pente ascendante qui augmente
de 9% sur un an et bref ce numérique
risque de devenir insoutenable pour la
planète puisque c'est un gouffre
énergétique un grand consommateur de
matière première donc le secteur du
numérique génère autant de gaz à effet
plus de gaz à effet de serre que
l'aviation que vous avez souvent cité et
2018-2050 on nous dit que à ce rythme
elle représenteront 35% des émissions
des émissions en tout cas donc ma
question est la suivante ce numérique
qui a quelque peu quand même bénéficié à
l'environnement
ne suffit pas à compenser sa propre
empreinte numérique on a pensé
on a compté sur la des matérialisation
pour économiser des arbres mais au bout
du compte quand on fait l'addition le
compte pas alors que pensez-vous
monsieur Jean-Côme de cette ce
développement exponentiel de ces tweets
et retweets futile
inutiles pensez-vous qu'il ne faudrait
pas aujourd'hui réfléchir à
responsabiliser voire à réguler l'usage
du numérique
merci Monsieur Mazard merci synthétique
merci monsieur le Président désolé
monsieur donc ici je vais vous obliger
encore à parler un petit peu de
nucléaire
quand on rencontre nos concitoyens alors
qu'ils sont pas farouchement hostile au
nucléaire ils expriment donc deux
craintes concernant le nucléaire la
première crainte et vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure c'est quid des déchets et
vous avez dit que c'était peut-être un
peu disproportionné la crainte qu'on
pouvait avoir sur le traitement de l'eau
déchets par rapport à la technologie qui
semble assez assez
efficace à la matière mais en tout cas
le peu de risque objectif qui que
représente ces déchets et après la
deuxième crème qui est exprimée c'est la
sécurisation des sites eux-mêmes des
sites nucléaires par rapport aux
catastrophes nucléaires ou par rapport à
des attaques et on voit ce qui se passe
à l'Ukraine actuellement quel est votre
votre avis là pour pour pourquoi pas
aussi rassurer nos concitoyens sur ce
sujet ou est-ce que c'est une crainte
qu'il faut prendre véritablement sérieux
et qui peut être un écueil au
développement du nucléaire et puis un
mot sur sur l'énergie produite par nos
grands ouvrages hydroélectriques vous
savez que qu'aujourd'hui certaines
normes de ces ouvrages
sont exploités par
[Musique]
des exploitants historiques mais à qui
on demande donc de remettre donc à la
concurrence donc fin demande à l'état en
tout cas de remettre la concurrence donc
l'exploitation de ces grands barrages
hydroélectriques alors là on est sur un
problème de souveraineté qui est palier
à la technologie ou aux procédures mais
qui est liée donc à celui qui demain
pourrait piloter ces grands ouvrages
quelle est votre sentiment sur le sujet
et est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
l'orientation qui semble être prise
concernant notamment l'opérateur EDF
avec la nationalisation semble aller
dans le bon dans la bonne direction
alors madame Babou et puis ensuite on
aura fini des questions
merci monsieur le Président oui je
voulais tout d'abord revenir sur les
dérivés du plastique des ruines du
pétrole dont vous évoquez si vous pouvez
éventuellement développer vous avez
parlé de la mobilité des bâtiments mais
restait effectivement les plastiques du
quotidien et notamment dans la partie
alimentaire
la deuxième question c'est sur le bilan
de carbone sur le bilan carbone vous en
êtes l'auteur on parle souvent des
missions carbone mais bien moins de
bilan et pour nos prises de décision je
pense qu'il serait intéressant et
j'aimerais savoir si ça si cela existe
alors dans de nombreux domaines mais
aussi sur l'énergie un bilan carbone sur
l'ensemble des solutions que nous avons
évoquées quelque chose de précis et de
clair qui serait ma collègue parlait
tout à l'heure de rationnel là au moins
ce serait intangible ce serait factuel
merci voilà alors on vous laisse en la
parole je vous pose une dernière
question un peu bonus
voilà privilège du président
cuite des fuites carbone
autre que naturel
vous voulez parler de l'aspirateur assez
de islandais
alors
de numérique vous avez raison j'ai
mauvaise conscience
bah oui
le numérique je vais d'abord le relier à
la au thème de cette commission c'est un
domaine dans lequel nous n'avons aucune
souveraineté aucune c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui pour payer mes impôts je
dépends des Gafa
c'est la fonction la plus régalienne de
l'État qui est de lever l'impôt a été
confiée au Gafa j'ai besoin d'un
ordinateur
j'ai besoin d'un système internet qui
est pas opéré j'ai besoin d'un système
mondial de télécommunication tout ça il
y a plus rien de il y a plus rien dans
cette affaire qui relève de la
souveraineté française
le ce qu'on vient de faire sur la 5G de
mon point de vue un abandon
supplémentaire de souveraineté puisque
on va obliger les français on va inciter
pour être plus exact les opérateurs
français à s'équiper avec des tas de
composants de réseau qui sont pas
fabriqués en France on va inciter les
Français à changer de smartphone pour
des appareils qui sont pas fabriqués en
France donc c'est quelque chose qui est
tout ça pour regarder Netflix dans le
métro enfin je suis pas complètement
convaincu et pour avoir tinder qui
marche mieux du reste au moins Free est
honnête dans ses campagnes de pub donc
le opération du genou de madame je sais
pas quoi en Creuse là en fait non c'est
pas ça que ça va servir donc on a on est
clairement aujourd'hui dans ce que
j'appelle les briété numérique alors
avant de savoir si la première chose à
faire est de fermer le compte Youtube de
gens comme ici ce qui est une option
puisque comme ça on s'est barbarie ça
supprimera de la pollution numérique
je fais ce que je peux regarder en très
basse définition mais bon c'est clair
que j'y participe aussi donc ça question
pour moi aussi
il y a quand même alors si on repart du
début l'empreinte carbone du numérique
aujourd'hui dans le monde c'est à moitié
fabrication des équipements à moitié
opération des équipements dans les
équipements vous avez tous les écrans
connectés là qui sont autour de cette
table enfin autour de cette salle pardon
vous avez les ordinateurs vous avez les
smartphones vous avez les composants de
réseau voilà ça c'est les serveurs et
l'opération de ces équipements donc
l'électricité c'est l'autre moitié ce
qui tire aujourd'hui extrêmement
fortement donc vous avez raison de me
chatouiller sur Youtube ce qui tire
aujourd'hui extrêmement fortement la
croissance du trafic du système digital
mondial c'est la vidéo en ligne alors
les gens qui font du streaming la
Netflix en tête YouTube est un gros
pourvoyeur également de trafic data le
porno est également un gros pourvoyeur
de trafic data et après vous avez toutes
les vidéos du petit dernier qui fait
avoir eux que les gens s'envoient
et qui est quelque chose de nul
important pour en général pour les
récipendaires mais très important pour
les gens qui expédient la vidéo et donc
le
donc la question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on limite l'inflation de tout ça
alors il y a quelques suggestions qu'on
avait faites à l'époque au chiffre
projet on avait proposé à la recette que
les accords enfin que les licences
octroyées aux opérateurs soient faites
sous conditions de maîtrise de
l'empreinte carbone
d'option
à l'époque il nous avait qu'à moitié
rayonné enfin il nous avait ils avaient
noté l'idée voilà il faudra probablement
c'est toujours pareil à partir du moment
où on veut limiter un usage avec deux
options c'est les quantités ou les prix
et aussi project on est un peu plus
communiste donc on préfère les quantités
que les prix on pense que c'est plus
égalitaire de limiter par les quantités
que de limiter par les prix
il va clairement falloir se poser la
question et par ailleurs aujourd'hui la
débauche d'équipement qu'on est en train
d'utiliser pour des usages totalement
récréatifs le metaves etc donc je ne
suis pas complètement convaincu qu'ils
vont aider à faire pleuvoir ou à se
sortir un peu mieux de la situation
qu'on est en train de décrire ici c'est
autant de composants qu'on ne pourra
plus mettre dans des choses qui
aujourd'hui sont indispensables au
fonctionnement quotidien de notre
société avoir des banques aujourd'hui
les banques c'est quoi c'est des
électrons et des ordinateurs c'est ça
une banque aujourd'hui c'est d'accord
sans sans électronique ça n'existe plus
une banque si demain matin on devait
revenir au billet de banque et au
comptable sur feuille de papier système
explose donc c'est ces usages là qui
sont même si on dit beaucoup de mal des
banques par ailleurs il y a des usages
comme ça qui aujourd'hui sont devenus
essentiels à très court terme
et on est en train de entre guillemets
gaspiller des ressources pour des trucs
assez futile au détriment de la
possibilité de garder des trucs qu'on va
devoir garder un peu plus longtemps plus
longtemps précisément voilà donc il y a
un vrai sujet là-dessus il me semble que
ça justifierait également des
investigations un peu plus approfondie
de l'enceinte dans laquelle je me trouve
de se pencher sur qu'est-ce qu'on fait
en termes de stratégie du numérique dans
ce pays à part céder à la fascination
devant le gadget et je suis désolé de
dire à votre groupe notre président en
tête
alors
ensuite en ce qui concerne on va quand
même tous vu au Consumer Show de Las
Vegas avec des lunettes virtuelles etc
enfin bon je dis c'est pas un secret
après il y avait un sujet sur la
sécurisation
des sites enfin la question des
accidents sur les sites
alors les
un accident est toujours possible c'est
clair que il faut vivre avec cette idée
moi en sortant d'ici je peux me faire
renverser par un camion c'est donc un
accident est toujours possible
la question c'est est-ce que compte tenu
des avantages que nous offre les
dispositifs non accidentés on est prêt à
courir le risque de l'accident et le
risque de l'accident aujourd'hui le plus
important c'est le risque de panique en
fait c'est pas tellement le risque c'est
pas tellement le dommage physique lié à
l'accident c'est le fait qu'aujourd'hui
le nucléaire encore une fois j'ai jamais
percé complètement les raisons de tout
ça
engendre des réactions qui sont
disproportionnées par rapport à la
cigarette par rapport à la circulation
routière ou par rapport à un aliment
dont je ne redonnerai pas le nom ici
parce que ça devient suffisamment fait
le buzz comme ça mais c'est mais voilà
quand on regarde les risques concours en
fait
qu'est-ce qui se passe en cas d'accident
sur un réacteur à eau pressurisé le plus
probable c'est qu'il se passe la même
chose que ce qui s'est passé à prima
Island c'est à dire que vous perdez le
réacteur à l'intérieur de l'enceinte de
confinement point qu'est-ce qui se passe
si vous avez un conflit alors à ce
moment le vrai problème c'est est-ce que
l'accident enfin la vraie question c'est
est-ce que l'accident va rajouter côté
de façon massive des dommages par
rapport aux dommages du conflit
c'est ça la question donc la question
c'est s'il y a un accident les aporidia
est-ce que ça change significativement
le bilan de la guerre en Ukraine et la
réponse est malheureusement non
donc quand il y a un dommage à une
installation parce qu'il y a eu guerre
le vrai problème c'est la guerre c'est
quand même ça le vrai problème c'est
bien ça qu'il faut comprendre
après vous avez des tas de manière de
faire plein de morts avec des dommages
aux installations de production
électrique et du reste dans la même la
convention
j'adore les guerres et conventions je
veux bien que tu me tues et d'une
certaine manière seulement
normalement on ne porte pas atteinte aux
centrales nucléaires quand on se fait la
guerre mais on ne porte pas non plus
atteint au barrage figurez-vous et or si
vous voulez faire beaucoup de dégâts
très rapidement on voit beaucoup mieux
beaucoup mieux dézinguer les barrages
que dézinguer des centrales nucléaires
si on faisait sauter le barrage de
Vouglans en France ça mettrait 6 mètres
d'eau place Bellecour à Lyon je peux
vous assurer que ça ferait plus de morts
que bon donc c'est c'est donc c'est quoi
la c'est quoi la bonne réponse en fait
elle tient dans un mot que j'ai pas
prononcé jusqu'à maintenant qui est
pédagogique
l'époque va probablement demander que
votre métier comporte plus qu'avant
le fait de faire la pédagogie des
problèmes alors je sais bien que pour un
élu normalement on fait la pédagogie des
solutions mais non mais de temps en
temps je pense que vous allez pas couper
au fait de faire aussi la pédagogie des
problèmes de et pour la seule manière
d'y arriver c'est de vous en imprégner
vous-même c'est-à-dire d'être vous-même
capable de maîtriser à peu près les
sujets sur le plan technique alors ça en
fait de plus je sais très bien que ça
vient en plus de la sécurité sociale de
la production agricole de la façon dont
on enseigne le français au collège et de
ce qui se passe dans les quartiers où il
y a trop d'immigrés donc ça vient en
plus de tout ça mais
il va falloir le faire quand même
quand je dis trop c'est pas un jugement
de valeur c'est pour représenter le
débat public
pardon
vous pouvez le laisser c'est une figure
de style
après il y avait un sujet sur une
question sur l'hydroélectricité
et du coup j'ai pas noté la question
j'ai juste noté que c'était l'hydro
alors l'ouverture à la concurrence du
site ouais alors je me suis je me suis
exprimé de manière générale sur
l'ouverture à la concurrence des
systèmes électriques en disant que ça
avait été une connerie
et je le pense toujours que on a
essentiellement perdu notre temps à
faire quelque chose qui n'a apporté
aucun mais il y a aucun élément positif
rien ça servi à rien ça a servi à
enrichir des distributeurs ça a servi à
divertir de la rente par rapport aux
propriétaires des dispositifs de
production ça a servi à créer des effets
de volatilité dans les prix de marché
dont en ce moment on était en train de
voir les effets à plein ça a servi à
rien d'utile voilà donc est-ce qu'il
faut aller encore plus loin dans cette
direction bah vous avez la réponse la
réponse est non
qu'est-ce que ça demande de rétropédaler
sur ce sujet bah ça demande que la
France prenne son bâton de pèlerin et
ail commencer à militer et donc faire la
pédagogie du problème aussi auprès de
nos amis européens puisque c'est une ça
dépend d'une décision en disant que
peut-être que l'époque voudrais que on
arrête ce genre de système qui n'a
strictement aucun intérêt et que on
revienne à quelque chose de plus intégré
qui permet de faire de la planification
sur le long terme parce que le maître
mot en matière de système énergétique
cette planifier et quand vous avez un
marché ouvert la planification est
impossible
donc vous pouvez faire de la délégation
on aurait pu faire de l'ouverture à
Lamont sur on aurait pu dire bon on fait
un duo-paul dans ce pays quand on en a
marre des DF on prend engie quand on en
a marre d'engie on prend un DF on sait
exactement ce qu'on a fait dans l'eau
c'est ce qu'on vous avez plein de dans
les infrastructures très capitalistiques
c'est ce qui finit par se passer
c'est-à-dire oligopole régulé on peut
discuter de savoir si un oligopole
régulé c'est mieux qu'un monopole
d'accord mais c'est le seul truc qui est
qui qui soit compatible avec le fait que
vous avez besoin d'opérateurs capables
d'assumer des investissements lourds
voilà la concurrence à Laval était un
truc qui n'avait aucun intérêt
alors les usages du plastique on peut
faire de des plastiques avec de la
chimie avec de la biomasse puisque dans
les hydrocarbures et du carbone et
d'hydrogène donc dans la biomasse vous
pouvez récupérer du carbone et de
l'hydrogène et après pareil faire des
faire des plastiques tu restes
aujourd'hui vous avez des plastiques qui
sont faits à partir des thanol de canne
à sucre à partir d'un million de
est-ce qu'on en fera autant que le
plastique qu'on fait avec le vrai
pétrole je ne sais pas est-ce que ça
sera aussi facile ça non ça sera
nécessairement plus compliqué
et après la question c'est à partir du
moment où on tape dans la biomasse en
fait il y a toujours une question
systémique à laquelle il faut être enfin
le système à laquelle il faut être
capable de répondre la biomasse c'est à
dire l'espace vous pouvez en faire
quatre choses différentes vous pouvez
vous en servir pour manger vous pouvez
vous en servir pour avoir des matériaux
des fibres du bois du chanvre du lin etc
du coton vous pouvez vous en servir pour
avoir de l'énergie
du bois bûche cette fois-ci pas du bois
d'oeuvre des agrocarbures etc et vous
pouvez vous en servir pour fiche la paix
à ce qui s'y trouve ça s'appelle
préserver la biodiversité et de temps en
temps vous pouvez un peu combiner les
usages par exemple vous pouvez faire une
agriculture qui soit plus ou moins
nocive pour la biodiversité donc vous
pouvez avoir des des combinaisons vous
pouvez faire de l'agriculture avec de
l'agroforesterie avoir un peu de bois
énergie ou avoir un peu de bois
matériaux
la question de combien de biomasse on
est capable d'utiliser pour faire du
plastique elle est donc indissociable de
la question de combien de biomasse j'ai
envie d'utiliser pour avoir de l'énergie
biogaz arocarburant etc combien de
biomasse je veux pour faire du bois
d'oeuvre combien etc et aujourd'hui la
seule chose que je peux vous dire c'est
que quand vous regardez les plans
sectoriels qui sont faits par les
secteurs industriels les uns derrière
les autres ça boucle pas c'est si vous
ajoutez simplement l'appel à la biomasse
du secteur aérien et du secteur de la
construction pour avoir du bois d'oeuvre
déjà ça en France vous excédez les
capacités de production et surface
constante rien que ça bon donc voilà
donc c'est en vous disant ça je ne vous
explique pourquoi je ne suis pas capable
de répondre à la question parce que la
seule bonne réponse c'est ça dépend de
ce que vous avez comme ambition sur les
usages concurrents de la biomasse il y a
pas de bouclage aujourd'hui qui est fait
entre secteurs alors dans le cadre du
plan de transformation de l'économie
française nous on a Facebook là et on a
tellement fait que on met très peu de
biomasse dans le PTF à cause de ça
il faut bien voir aussi qu'à l'avenir le
changement climatique va peser sur les
rendements agricoles la décrue de la
disponibilité fossile va peser sur les
rendements agricoles puisque en fait
quand on mange aujourd'hui on mange du
pétrole et du gaz on mange du pétrole
dans la mécanisation des engins de
transport et dans les transports amont
et aval j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure et
on mange du gaz dans la fabrication des
engraisés qui sont faits avec du gaz
donc dans la décrue on mange également
des engrais qui sont importés très loin
des phosphates et de la potasse c'est
l'exploitation minière donc avec ces on
mange enfin du pétrole pour les
phytosanitaires bon avec la décrue de
tout ça on va vous savez que la
mécanisation les phytosanitaires et les
engrais on fait multiplier le rendement
céréaliers en France par 5 en 30 ans
après guerre c'est évident que dans un
monde avec un climat plus hostile et
avec moins de combustibles fossiles
disponibles on va avoir une partie du
chemin inverse qui va se faire
question est-ce qu'on accepte par
exemple de manger moins de viande en
ayant pas plus de surface agricole
est-ce que on veut plus de surface
agricole pour manger toujours autant de
viande du coup vous aurez moins de
surfaces agricoles pour faire du bois
d'oeuvre du bois énergie et pour faire
des plastiques enfin oui donc c'est très
difficile de répondre à cette question
là de façon dissociée de la façon dont
on répond à plein d'autres questions y
compris sous contrainte enfin ou en
incluant plus exactement la contrainte
d'approvisionnement énergétique fossile
et la contrainte de dérive climatique
qui sont plutôt des choses qui vont
jouer dans le mauvais sens globalement
donc la réponse pour faire court c'est
qu'il va falloir en utiliser moins
[Musique]
et manger moins de viande c'est pas ou
c'est
voilà et après il va bien il va falloir
bien la choisir donc typiquement dans le
moins de viande qu'on mange c'est
évident qu'il faut d'abord commencer par
préserver ce qui vient des pâturages
parce que c'est des endroits où
valoriser plus facilement de la biomasse
avec des animaux et moins avec ceux qui
vient des grandes cultures qui vont
servir derrière à nourrir des animaux
etc enfin bon il y a tout un débat à
avoir là-dedans également qui a un débat
pas simple et il faut bien voir aussi
que il y a un vrai sujet dans cette
affaire
un aparté mais c'est très difficile de
demander un secteur qui est pas
globalement pas très riche à l'exception
de quelques acteurs mais laquelle
l'agriculture
de faire des innovations massives sans
que les Français acceptent de payer leur
nourriture un peu plus cher donc on a
aussi un sujet à ce niveau là
[Musique]
alors il y avait le bilan carbone des
sources énergétiques alors oui il y a
des sources énergétiques sur lesquelles
c'est très simple de faire une empreinte
carbone par exemple tous les modes
électriques c'est raisonnablement simple
avec parfois des variations par exemple
un panneau solaire selon vous le mettez
dans un désert chilien ou selon vous le
mettez dans la brume norvégienne il va
pas vous sortir la même quantité de
kilomètres panneau solaire qui aura émis
la même quantité de CO2 pour sa
fabrication parce qu'il faut de la
métallurgie parce qu'il faut fondre le
silicium parce que etc Il vous fera pas
la même quantité de kilowatt-heure à
l'arrivée sur sa durée de vie et donc le
contenu carbone en analyse de cycle de
vie du kilowatt-heure produit aura varié
par la force des choses mais on a quand
même des ordres de grandeur donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui est assez facile
à établir là où ça commence à devenir
plus difficile c'est pour certaines
énergies fossiles d'estimer les
émissions que dites fugitives
c'est-à-dire les émissions qui sont
liées à des fuites à Lamont et
particulièrement pour le gaz
puisque le gaz naturel c'est du méthane
et que le méthane est un gaz à effet de
serre donc les fuites de gaz naturel de
mémoire je vais pas dire de bêtises mais
de mémoire à 10% de 8% de fuite le gaz
naturel est aussi nocif que le charbon
pour le voilà 8% on les a pas en général
mais c'est quelques pourcent on peut les
avoir
donc il y a après pour des là où ça
devient plus compliqué c'est pas
tellement pour les sources énergétiques
c'est pour tout ce qui en est issus
c'est-à-dire si je veux faire
l'empreinte carbone de votre foulard
l'empreinte carbone de votre veste ou
l'empreinte carbone de ce micro là ça
devient plus compliqué parce que à
chaque fois il faut faire une
investigation approfondie sur les
sources énergétiques globalement les
ordres de grandeur sont assez facilement
disponibles là où vous allez avoir une
incertitude importante c'est sur les
sources issues de la biomasse parce que
ça renvoie la discussion qu'on a déjà eu
plusieurs fois c'est est-ce que c'est
associé à de la déforestation ou pas
parce que ça change le résultat d'un
ordre de grandeur en gros si c'est pas
associé à de la déforestation c'est
mieux que le fossile mais si c'est
associé à de la déforestation c'est pire
que les fossiles donc c'est là là il y a
quelque chose qui est vraiment
[Musique]
j'ai envie de dire ça fait vraiment
changer de résultat de nature
et c'est lié à quelque chose sur lequel
vous pouvez faire difficilement
autrement que de poser des hypothèses
alors le
dans les plus émissives vous allez
trouver en CO2 ça dépend ça dépend sur
quel paramètre par ailleurs parce que
vous pouvez regarder le CO2 vous pouvez
regarder l'espace au sol vous pouvez
regarder les particules fines voilà
alors si on parle de CO2 ce qui est la
plus nocive de le très loin c'est le
charbon ensuite arrive le pétrole
ensuite arrive le gaz mais le bois avec
des forestations c'est encore pire que
le charbon d'accord donc par exemple les
projets qui visent à remplacer pour un
certain nombre de pays où le bois de feu
est obtenu par déforestation les foyers
par des petits réchauds à gaz c'est pas
idiot
sans même parler de foyer solaire du
Butagaz de camping voilà donc
vous avez un donc c'est ça la hiérarchie
dans les modes donc dit non carbonés
c'est-à-dire où le fonctionnement même
n'aimait pas de CO2
la hiérarchie c'est que vous allez
trouver au plus haut vous allez trouver
le solaire en dessous vous allez trouver
à peu près à parité l'hydroélectricité
l'éolien et le nucléaire avec des
petites variations en fonction des
spécificités locales voilà mais en gros
c'est comme ça que ça se avec un facteur
3 4 on va dire entre le solaire et le et
le reste le reste vous êtes entre 5 et
10 g de CO2 par kilowattheure électrique
le solaire vous êtes entre 20 et 50 en
fonction de des conditions d'insolation
etc
ça c'est sans tenir compte du stockage
parce que quand vous stockez vous perdez
20 à 40% enfin avec des modes classiques
donc soit step step vous perdez 25 %
batterie vous perdez 20 % et il faut
faire la batterie
ce qui émet également du CO2 comme vous
le savez probablement dans une voiture
électrique la fabrication de la batterie
c'est la moitié des émissions de
fabrication de la voiture donc si vous
rajoutez les émissions du stockage pour
le soleil vous pouvez dépasser les 100 g
en mode purement électrique le gaz est à
400 g de CO2 par kilowattheure
électrique le pétrole à 800 et le
charbon à 1000 en ordre de grandeur
les puits de carbone technologiques bon
entre en très court vous oubliez
il y a un truc qui technologiquement
peut fonctionner c'est de ne pas émettre
c'est à dire la capture et séquestration
mais récupérer le CO2 une fois qu'il est
dans l'air avec des modes technologiques
ça c'est un truc de Shadok
le CO2 est une molécule qui est
chimiquement inerte
c'est chimiquement inerte le CO2 une
fois que vous avez une molécule chimique
moyenne diluée à 0,04 % dans un milieu
aussi peu dense que l'air et bien pour
aller récupérer le CO2 là-dedans vous
avez une dépense énergétique qui est
tellement considérable
que en fait c'est un truc que vous ne
pourrez jamais déployer à l'échelle
alors j'ai fait un petit calcul d'ordre
de grandeur avec le truc islandais qui a
fait un peu le buzz l'aspirateur assez
Vendée islandais et mon calcul c'est que
si on voulait avec ce genre de
dispositif qui s'appelle dans le jargon
anglais d'arachter donc DAC la totalité
de nos émissions annuelles
reprendre dans l'atmosphère après avoir
émis la totalité de nos émissions
annuelles il faudrait y consacrer la
totalité de l'électricité annuelle et la
totalité du pétrole consommait dans le
monde tous les ans donc en gros on
aurait un truc de Shadok parfait où
l'énergie ne servirait qu'à une chose
c'est à récupérer le CO2 qu'on met dans
l'air grâce à cause de l'énergie voilà
bon je suis pas complètement persuadé
que ce soit quelque chose derrière
lequel il fait se précipiter donc
aujourd'hui comme l'argent coule à flot
partout parce qu'il y a eu la création
monétaire dans tous les sens vous
trouvez quelques fonds d'investissement
qui investissent dans ce genre de truc
mais c'est voilà ça les occupe mais en
gros ça ne servira à peu près à rien
pour changer le destin du monde
merci donc pour cette conclusion par
laquelle vous nous
inviter à penser que pour l'instant le
génie de l'homme n'a pas encore régalé
la photosynthèse en gros
le génie de l'homme va avoir beaucoup de
mal à y aller un certain nombre de
merveilles de la nature vous savez on
est d'accord
[Musique]
la consacré à répondre aux questions de
notre commission d'enquête ça permet de
brosser large et de et de
progressivement entrer dans les sujets
qui seront peut-être davantage les
processus décisionnels que les choix
technologiques parce que ça contribue
aussi à la façon dont on prendra pendant
le dans le futur les décisions publiques
merci à toutes et à tous pour votre
participation et puis je vous dis à la
semaine prochaine monsieur le rapporteur